So, who's to us?
Hallo, Pucks, Twitch, AliExpress.
Okay, ich will mich echt unbedingt auf die Login-Seite weiterleiten, was auch immer.
Mal ein paar Tabs zu machen.
Jo, es geht weiter.
Geht's aus.
Ich muss erst noch das Pepega-Board starten.
Und noch einen Twitch-Post machen.
Äh, Twitter-Post.
Warum heißt das auch so ähnlich?
Wobei, man macht ja keinen Twitter-Post, man tweetet ja.
In zwei bis drei Stunden.
Es könnte sein, dass ich da noch on bin.
Licky, das könnte noch sein.
Aber das wird knapp.
Alter, sag mal, haben die in diesem komischen Chill-Dings immer das gleiche läuft?
Ich hab extra jetzt schon weitergedrückt als das letzte Mal.
Wupp, wupp, wupp.
Eieiei.
Starten wir den Krempel mal.
Pepega-Board muss gestartet werden.
Hast du schon immer so viel gestreamt? Nein.
Hehehe.
Der heilige BimBam ist auch da.
Mit Emoji-Support.
Ja, allerdings gefaked.
Ich hab einfach einen Browser-Add-on installiert, was Twitch-Emojis kann.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen, ich hab's ausgetrickst.
So, ich wollte noch einen Twitter-Post machen.
So, Twitter-Post ist raus.
Ähm, ja, ja, Zorgon gibt es.
Ich hab sogar schon was gefunden.
Das einzige, also die offizielle Twitter-Post, die ich noch nicht gefunden habe, ist die Twitter-Post.
Also, die offizielle Twitter-Post.
Twitch-API ist schlecht zu, ist ein bisschen blöd zu verwenden.
Da brauchst du einen API-Token und alles.
Aber es gibt off-, es gibt freie Twitch-APIs, die das für einen machen.
Guck da halb schatten, da taucht er auf.
So, die Frage haben wir beantwortet.
Das haben wir auch beantwortet.
Auch.
Haben wir auch beantwortet vorhin.
Haben wir auch, haben wir auch, haben wir auch.
Okay, keine offenen Fragen.
Bam. Easy.
So.
Also, was wir jetzt machen ist, wir machen zwei Sachen.
Zuerst einmal, machen wir, ich verschiebe das mal kurz.
Einmal basteln wir heute ein bisschen Arduino ESP32 wieder, aber vorher, aber vorher, ja, mach.
Aber vorher kaufen wir in China ein.
Und zwar kaufen wir ein bei...
Ich hab mich sogar eingeloggt bei AliExpress.
Ich muss jetzt gucken, dass ich nichts leake.
Weil AliExpress lässt mich nicht mal suchen neuerdings.
Wenn ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
Und das liegt an Unity Media.
Oder ich könnte wetten, dass es an Unity Media liegt.
Dass zu viel aus diesem Unity Media Netz komische Dinger bei AliExpress machen und deswegen AliExpress das gesperrt hat.
Was auch immer, ist egal. Ich bin eingeloggt. Normalerweise liegt da nichts.
Genau, also meine drei China-Sachen.
Meine drei Seiten der Wahl, um billiges Elektronik-Zeug einzukaufen.
Name liegt, Max, ja. Hi, Max.
Also meine Top-3-Seiten, wo ich immer einkaufe in China, China-Kram.
Es ist nicht die exklusiven Seiten, allerdings.
Hauptsächlich, das ist AliExpress GearBest und sieht auch alles relativ ähnlich aus.
Und das beste Seite.
Banggood.
Ich finde, Banggood hört sich so ein bisschen so hier an.
Aber sie meinen damit wahrscheinlich, dass man...
Ich weiß nicht, was sie damit meinen.
Äh, die H-Gate habe ich noch nicht bestellt.
Ich habe, ich habe ein paar China-Shops schon bestellt.
Das sind aber so die drei großen eigentlich.
Die H-Gate habe ich noch nicht bestellt.
Aber die sind öfters auch in den Suchanfragen drinne.
Ja.
Sind das, sind das...
Grill!
Sind das die Dropshipper, wo die ganzen Dropshipper sind, die H-Gate?
Okay, also die denken schon mal, ich bin sehr interessiert an weiblicher Sommerbekleidung.
Ja, es gibt zig, zig, zig China-Seiten.
Allerdings den besten Namen hat eindeutig Banggood.
Da wird mal ordentlich gebängt.
Gut, wird da gebängt, ja.
Äh, Zolgon, die habe ich gestern auch gefunden.
Siehe, siehe hier.
Die hatte ich auch gestern gefunden.
Da.
Das Problem mit der Lib ist, die ist Node.js exklusiv.
Also das ist, das ist irgendeine Node.js-Lib, die kann man nicht im Browser verwenden.
Und ich muss die ja im Browser verwenden.
Sollte man die doch irgendwie im Browser verwenden können, dann mache ich das damit.
Aber so wie es für mich aussieht, kann man die nicht im Browser verwenden.
Sondern nur in Node.
Ich lasse mich aber gerne eines Besseren belehren.
Das PPGA-Board aktualisiert übrigens nicht automatisch.
Äh, schon, schon jemals.
Das, das ist richtig praktisch, hier das Teil.
Das ist richtig nice.
Sonst hätte ich die Frage übersehen vom, vom, ähm, Mond der Welt.
Wo?
Mond?
Ach, Mo-, Mond Everest.
Jetzt habe ich es gecheckt.
Äh, ähm.
Ähm.
Schon jemals Pakete vom Zoll abge-, abgefangen.
Und versenden die von die EU.
Das kommt drauf an.
Ähm, also ja, ich hatte schon einige Pakete beim Zoll.
Allerdings aus China kann ich mich jetzt noch nicht dran erinnern.
Ich will es nicht ausschließen.
Allerdings, ähm, aus den USA landet der Kram immer beim Zoll.
Die, ähm, die China-Händler haben es anscheinend perfektioniert, die Sachen ordentlich zu deklarieren.
So, dass sie nicht vom Zoll festgehalten werden.
Wer weiß, was die da draufschreiben.
Wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Blödsinn.
Ähm.
So, und ob die die EU versenden, hängt von folgendem ab.
Man kann mal angenommen, wir suchen jetzt mal über Banggood irgendwas.
Wir suchen jetzt mal, keine Ahnung, USB.
Wir suchen jetzt einfach irgendwas, wo es drei Milliarden Seiten gibt mit, mit USB.
Und dann kann man hier oben irgendwo auswählen.
Warehouse.
Und dann kann man sagen EU Warehouse.
So, und jetzt hat man quasi alles, was direkt von der EU verschickt wird.
Allerdings ist das auch ein bisschen, ein bisschen fake.
Weil wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel mal, keine Ahnung, gehen wir jetzt mal hier irgendwie auf, auf, auf irgend so ein Arduino, ja.
Ähm.
Und jetzt sieht man, okay, in dem Fall stimmt's.
Ich nehm's zurück, in dem Fall stimmt's.
Ähm, da wird oftmals auch ein bisschen Blödsinn angezeigt.
Also, man stellt auf EU Warehouse und guckt danach und stellt fest, es kommt doch aus China oder Russland.
Vielleicht ist ja Russland Warehouse bei denen EU Warehouse.
Keine Ahnung.
Was ich merk, wenn ich finde, dass es den Franzosen Warehouse gibt.
So, ist doch French, oder?
Wir stellen mal, wir stellen mal auf Französisch um.
Ey, das ist immer die gleiche Playlist.
Das, das geht mir auf den Sack.
Ich brauch jetzt irgendwas anderes.
Gaming Mix.
Dubstep.
Wupp, wupp, wupp.
Besser gesagt.
Ja, das geht auch.
Cute Chat.
Cute as fuck ist der Chat hier.
Oh, Mann.
Aller Twitch ist es schon, ey.
Normaler.
So, jetzt haben wir auf Französisches Warehouse umgestellt.
Und tatsächlich, ich find's ja immer wieder geil, ne?
Was, was gibt's für, das ist wieder voll passiert.
Es gibt All Warehouses, Hongkong, USA, EU und Frankreich.
Als wären die Franzosen nicht in der Lage, im EU Warehouse zu bestellen.
Ja.
UK würd ich ja noch verstehen jetzt.
In Zukunft.
Was auch immer.
Das muss man nicht verstehen.
Browser, Browsify, ja, hab ich schon gelesen, hab ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Aber das PPGA Board ist echt nice.
Das kann ich sagen.
Okay.
Frage beantwortet.
Zack.
Vergess ich nix.
Das lass ich einfach mal drinstehen, dass ich das nächste Mal dran denk.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Nice.
Okay, also.
Ich brauch, brauch ein paar Sachen.
Aus China.
Und zwar, das erste, wo ich schon ne ganze Weile danach such, sind, ähm.
Battlefield 3 Videos, da ist.
Oh, ist das schon lang her.
Ähm.
Zwar.
Ich brauch ein paar Sachen aus China, wo ich jetzt, wo ich schon ganz lang danach such.
Und letztens in der Suchmaschine was gefunden hab, sind Kabel.
Allerdings.
Ähm.
Nur in Rot und nur in Schwarz.
Oder in, in Single, in Singelfarbe such ich welche.
Wie alt bist du jetzt?
Ich bin 21.
Wir werden alt.
Pff.
21, äh.
Ich werd, ich werd nächsten Monat 35.
Also.
21 alt, äh.
I'll make a little.
Nächste Woche 35, äh.
Easy.
eine Rolle irgendwie gelber
und blauer. Das reicht mir. Grün
vielleicht. Und den Rest brauche ich alles gar nicht.
Und ich habe letztens in einem China-Shop
gesehen,
dass die...
Dann cremt ihr das doch selber.
Ah, das könnte ich im Prinzip
machen.
Ah, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ich habe lieber...
Ich glaube, ich habe sogar eine Zange für Dupont-Kabel.
Dupont-Kabel,
Dupont-Wires, Dupont-Jumper-Kabel,
wie auch immer das Zeug genau heißt.
Ich habe sogar, glaube ich, irgendwo eine Zange dafür.
Ich habe mir mal so ein paar
Zangen-Crem-Sets
gekauft für alles mögliche.
Netzwerkkabel, Dupont-Kabel,
Ader-Endhülsen-Crem-Ding.
Habe ich nicht einmal
verwendet, aber habe ich eine Box.
Ich wusste bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt
gar nicht mal, dass es Ader-Endhülsen...
Moment, hieß das überhaupt so?
Ich wusste bis dahin gar nicht, dass es so etwas
überhaupt gibt.
Ader-Endhülsen, tatsächlich.
Ich wusste, wie gesagt,
ich wusste, dass es so etwas überhaupt gibt.
Ich wusste nicht mal, dass es das gibt.
Also immer.
Zumindest, das ist eigentlich ganz praktisch.
Mal was gucken.
Das ist eigentlich ganz praktisch,
wenn man,
ich zeige euch, wie das aussieht.
Da macht man Kabel rein.
Und,
also Kabel, so nützen Kabel,
so welche macht man da rein, genau.
So welche.
Da macht man das drüber und dann krimpt man das fest.
Und dann gibt es einfach einen viel festeren
und größeren Kontakt, den man dann reinschrauben kann.
Das ist eigentlich ganz praktisch.
Habe ich aber noch nie verwendet.
Freust du dich auf den Moment,
wenn Bad Company 3 als Trailer erscheint?
Unglaublich, ey.
Ich habe ein Tool zum Netzwerkkabel krimpen,
allerdings ist das kacke.
Das ist so viel rumgefädelt
und gefuddelt, da habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Ich brauche nur ein fertiges Netzwerkkabel.
Okay, so, und zwar, ich hätte gerne,
und das habe ich letztens in der Suche...
Ah ja, nee, das ist ein Kabelbinder.
Genau, so was,
hätte ich im Endeffekt gerne.
Ich hätte gerne einen Haufen
fertig gekrimpter Kabel
in diesen Farben.
Genau in diesen Farben hätte ich das gerne.
Und ich habe keinen Bock, selber zu krimpen.
Gefuddelt da, ey.
Wo habe ich das denn gesehen?
Komplett in schwarz
gab es die und in rot.
Dann doch AliExpress.
Ja!
Ja, nice!
Das brauche ich!
Pock!
Moment, ich muss mal meinen eigenen Ordner machen.
Äh,
Add Folder.
China.
Wo ist der China Folder?
China Folder.
Speichern. China.
Das brauche ich, genau so was suche ich.
Einfach ein Bündel.
Was sind denn das hier? 200 Stück.
Das ist gut.
Genau, genau das, was ich brauche.
Am besten wäre es,
wenn die noch hier die lila Dinger weglassen würden,
wenn die braunen Dinger einfach doppelt soviel schwarz und rote Kabel hinmachen.
Die brauche ich.
Haben die sonst noch was?
Ja gut, das ist zum selber machen.
Oder?
Was ist denn das?
Da fehlt die Hülse drumherum, ne?
Das ist ja Mist.
Halbfertig.
Ja, das, easy.
Das wird bestellt.
AliExpress.
Fünf Pack.
Dann habe ich die nächsten, nächsten Jahre Ruhe.
Sind nur Female to Female.
Zum größten Teil brauche ich auch Female to Female.
Weil die ganzen GPIO Pins sind Pins.
Und die meisten Sensor sind auch Pins.
Ja, aber du hast recht.
Ab und zu mal braucht man auch noch einen Female to Male oder Male to Female.
Female to Male, Black.
Optimal.
Ist auch gekauft.
China.
AliExpress regelt.
Perfekt.
Aber das sind random Farben.
Nice.
Okay.
AliExpress hat sich schon mal rentiert.
Das muss, das wird bestellt.
Auf jeden Fall brauche ich.
Von diesen Kabeln kann man generell nie genug haben.
So, mal in das PPGA Board gucken.
Ob ich da irgendwas übersehen habe.
Battlefield 3 haben wir beantwortet.
Grimpen selber machen wir nicht.
Ja, wie gesagt, auf Bad Company 3 freue ich mich übertrieben.
Wobei ich habe das Gefühl,
ich lasse mich mit Bad Company 3 übelst hypen.
Wir zacken.
Weil die einfach verlernt haben, wie man ordentlich Battlefield Games macht.
Oh, eine Donation.
Da kann ich ja gleich noch mehr China Zeug bestellen.
5 Euro.
Ich hoffe du bist
auf der Gamescom 2019.
Dann gebe ich dir ein Bier aus
für den tollen Video.
Ich habe jetzt nicht weiter lesen können, weil die Nachricht verschwunden ist.
Aber ich bin nicht auf der Gamescom 2019.
Geh nicht mal auf die Gamescom.
Unglaublich sinnlos Messe mittlerweile.
Hast du am 13.7. Geburtstag?
Ne, ich habe gesagt nächsten Monat.
Nächsten Monat ist nicht der 13.7.
Ich habe August Geburtstag.
26, na gut.
Sinn plus 9 Jahre Unterschied dann.
Ja, aber Bad Company 3 bin ich schon
ultra gehypt drauf.
Ich hoffe das, ich meine es deutet alles drauf hin.
Aber man weiß ja nie,
ob es dann am Ende auch so wird.
So, okay.
Also das erste China Ding haben wir schon gefunden.
Äh.
Als nächstes wollte ich mal schauen,
ob ich günstig
noch einen zweiten
Staubsauger Roboter kriege von denen,
die ich habe.
Habe ich zugemacht aus versehen.
Also bei Banggood schon mal nicht.
Jetzt hier was.
Oh, das ist nochmal ganz schön
unterschiedlich im Preis.
Banggood, ja bester Name, ne?
Da muss es klatschen bei Banggood.
Viel zu teuer.
43% off.
Und dann immer noch 379.
Wollen die uns verarschen?
Das ist viel zu teuer.
Viel, viel, viel
zu teuer.
Ach Moment, Dollar.
Aber es sind Euro auch zu teuer.
Das ist ja bei Amazon billiger.
Warum immer ich diesen komischen Kack-Handyhalter kriege.
Äh.
Warum ist das so teuer auf einmal?
Ich habe den für 250 oder so gekriegt.
Das war aber gerade im Angebot.
Aber das ist ein Unterschied.
Ob 250 oder 420.
The fuck?
Alderlan.
Was ist hier los?
Warum ist das so teuer?
Mit Wischfunktion. Ja, aber die verwende ich nicht.
Der ist richtig gut.
Soll ich euch mal das Webinterface zeigen vom Staubsauger Roboter?
Äh.
Vorher muss ich noch sagen.
Vorher muss ich euch noch zeigen was das für ein Webinterface ist.
Das ist ja nicht das offizielle Webinterface.
Weil offiziell hat das Ding kein Webinterface.
So sieht das Teil in großer Aufnahme aus.
Ah.
Ähm.
Hier hinten.
Oder hier hinten.
Ich kann mir gar nicht merken auf welcher Seite der Behälter ist.
Da hat man einen Einschub für Wasser.
Und einen Einschub für den Mülleimer.
Allerdings ist der Mülleimer nicht sonderlich groß.
Man kann da auch so einen Lappen dran machen.
Verwende ich aber nicht.
Ähm. Ich zeige euch so ein Webinterface.
Dass das Webinterface drauf kommt.
Das ist ein Open Source Github Projekt.
Oh, ich muss mal gucken. Gibt es eine neue Version die ich schon installieren müsste?
Nö.
Ich habe nämlich schon Master installiert.
Nicht das letzte Release.
Bist du jetzt schon zu faul zum saugen?
Man vermeidet mit Staubsauger Roboter nicht,
dass man saugen muss.
Man muss seltener saugen.
Das ist schon mal nicht schlecht.
So. Ähm. Webinterface. Muss ich mal kurz raussuchen.
Und da,
dass man das Webinterface da drauf verwenden kann,
muss man halt
den Roboter flashen.
Das flashen ist ein bisschen abenteuerlicher
Vorgang. Ist auch schon jetzt ein paar Wochen
her, wo ich das gemacht habe. Ich habe es ja auf Twitter gepostet.
Ähm.
Ist ein bisschen abenteuerlich
gewesen. Ich überlege gerade wieder ganz
wie das nochmal funktioniert hat.
Man musste, genau, man musste sich das Repo irgendwie
runterladen.
Dann musste man irgendwelche
Skripts ausführen.
Dann hat man einen Raspberry gebraucht.
Über den konnte man
das dann irgendwie flashen. War ein bisschen abenteuerlich.
Aber nachdem man es mal gemacht hat,
war es eigentlich
ziemlich, ziemlich easy.
Genau. So. Und das Webinterface
sieht folgendermaßen aus.
Muss nur gucken, dass ich jetzt nicht aus Versehen
wieder irgendwas leake oder so.
Ähm.
Webinterface sieht so aus.
Kann man natürlich auch wunderbar mit Tablet bedienen.
Also das, ich bin
jetzt gerade auf meinem Staubsauger-Roboter drauf,
wer sich das fragt, ja. Also wir haben,
wir haben ja hier gerne Webinterfaces
und geflashte China-Sachen. Letztens
waren wir per Webinterface auf meiner Steckdosenleiste
drauf. Auf einer der vier Steckdosenleisten
drauf. Und heute sind wir
per Webinterface auf dem Staubsauger-Roboter
drauf.
Wir sind im Jahr 2019, ja.
Da hat auch der Staubsauger-Roboter ein Webinterface.
Und auf der Steckdosenleiste,
ja.
Steckdosenleiste haben wir letztens geflasht
mit, ähm,
Open-Source-Firmware
von, von GitHub.
Und jetzt kann man es, ähm, remote schalten
über das Webinterface, beziehungsweise über,
über API.
Das ist quasi für 29 Euro
eine, eine Vierfach-IP-Steckdosenleiste.
Sowas ist halt übelst teuer, wenn man sich
das fertig kauft.
Tja. Deine Steckdosenleiste hat kein
Prozessor. Die China-Steckdosenleiste
hat einen ESP
2866 drauf. Deswegen lässt sie sich auch
so schön flashen.
Streamt und redet über Staubsauger, wo andere Games spielen.
Gespielt habe ich heute Vormittag. Drei Stunden.
Wie heißt denn die Steckdosenleiste?
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen
Steckdosenleiste. Ich glaube, wir haben ein Kommando
dafür.
Steckdosenleiste oder Steckdose
oder so. Ausrufezeichen Steckdose,
Ausrufezeichen Steckdosenleiste.
Äh.
Äh, okay.
Einkauf schon durch? Nee.
Gerade dabei. Ich muss mal gucken, wie ist das denn,
das Kommando? Weil ich weiß selbst nicht mehr, wie das Ding
hieß.
Steckerleiste. Ausrufezeichen
Steckerleiste ist es.
Steckerleiste.
Hier,
hier ist, die ist das.
Äh, wer wissen will, wie
wir das geflasht haben, kann einfach im
Archiv gucken. Ähm.
Dann findet ihr den Stream, wo
wir das geflasht haben.
Die kostet 29 Euro.
Und, ähm.
Lässt sich mit das Motor flashen.
Das Ding kann man auf die Steckdosenleiste
drauf flashen. Total einfach.
Man braucht einfach nur einen Raspberry und
einen Skript. Da startet man
und der Rest macht das Skript.
Das ist easy.
Man könnte,
so teuer ist das nicht. 29 Euro ist okay.
In China ist der Kram auch nicht viel billiger.
Also 29 Euro
geht in Ordnung.
Beim Ikea für 5 Euro,
da habe ich meine Zweifel,
dass es beim Ikea
eine Steckdosenleiste gibt für 5 Euro.
Die man mit das Motor
flashen kann und dann, ähm.
Remote schalten kann.
Da habe ich irgendwie meine
Zweifel.
Wenn ja, schickt Ikea Link.
Link or it didn't happen.
Man braucht einen Raspberry mit WLAN, genau.
Brauchst einen Raspberry mit WLAN unbedingt, sonst geht's
nicht.
Da brennt doch die Bude weg.
Wie kommst du denn auf sowas?
Die hat selbstverständlich,
ähm.
Alle notwendigen
Prüfsiegel.
Monka Smoke.
Die hat sie wirklich. Allerdings haben die
die einfach nur aufgedruckt, gehe ich mal von aus.
Und was bringt das?
Naja, du kannst
die Steckdosenleiste schalten, ohne dass du dabei
sein musst.
Du kannst auch über deine Heimautomatisierung
schalten lassen.
Steckdosenleisten, schaltbare Steckdosenleisten
braucht man immer. Warum ich die flashen muss,
ist ganz einfach, oder musste.
Ist ganz einfach. Ähm.
Die unterstützt zwar Alexa und Gedöns
standardmäßig, allerdings
nur mit einer Smartphone-App
und auch nur mit der offiziellen Smartphone-App
und auch nur über die
China-Cloud. Also es ist nicht
etwa so, dass man quasi mit seinem Handy
die Steckdosenleiste schalten kann. Ne, ne.
Man lädt sich die offizielle
Steckdosenleisten-App runter,
die muss sich dann pairen mit der China-Cloud
und dann schaltest du deine Steckdosenleiste
mit dem Smartphone, wo du daneben
stehst, über die Cloud in China
an und aus. Das ist einfach nur
hirnrissig. Ähm, deswegen
habe ich die geflasht. Jetzt kann ich
per Webinterface drauf, ähm
genau, per Webinterface drauf
und die Sachen einfach
an- und ausschalten. Easy.
Und auch mein Home Assistant kann
über, also meine
Heimautomatisierungslösung, kann dann drauf
zugreifen, an- und ausschalten.
Genau. Aber zurück zum
Staubsaugerroboter.
In China geht der Server da und ich habe
eine Stromausfall. Ja, so ungefähr ist das.
Wenn du was schalten willst,
und die China-Cloud ist weg, dann geht's nicht.
Das gleiche Problem haben übrigens
die ganzen Leute, die sich ein Nest-Thermostat
gekauft haben.
Die können ihre Heizung nicht
einschalten, wenn der Server nicht da ist.
Das ist
unglaublich bescheuert.
Und noch viel schlimmer,
die Nest-API wird eingestellt.
Jetzt haben sie direkt gelitten.
Christi Gellmann hat dann GLHF.
Ähm,
genau, jetzt zurück zum Staubsaugerroboter.
Hallo Nick Hitz,
nee, Ninkitz.
Äh, zurück zum Staubsaugerroboter.
Also, wenn man den geflasht hat,
mit, äh,
Valetudo,
übelster Zungenbrecher der Name.
Doch, war er es letztens.
Jaja. Die Probleme gibt's
immer mal wieder, Leute, die Cloudlösungen
verwenden, dass sie dann ihre Heizung nicht ein- und ausschalten können.
Sowas kommt eigentlich laufend vor.
Beim größeren Ziel, beim kleineren Ziel.
Was macht eigentlich der Friseur?
Man ausruft und zeigt den Friseur,
der hat dann einen eigenen Stream, in dem er öfters MMOs streamt.
So, ähm,
zurück zum Staubsauger.
Jetzt endlich mal zeigen.
Das ist ein schönes Webinterface.
Lässt sich gut per Tablet
bedienen, wie man hier sieht.
Das ist so das typische Hamburger-Menü,
wie sich das nennt.
Ähm,
man kann hier einstellen,
Start, Stop, Pause.
Und dann kann man einfach
am Dock fahren,
weil aktuell ist er am Dock dran.
Ähm,
und ich hab das
vorm Stream schon mal vorbereitet,
das Ganze.
Weil ich hab die Karte gelöscht.
Normalerweise würde man hier jetzt quasi
den kompletten Grundriss und alles vom Haus sehen.
Ähm,
weil der hat so einen Laserscanner oben drauf
und scannt die Räume ab.
Ähm, wenn man will, dass er die Karte vergisst,
ist ganz einfach.
Einfach hochheben, Knopf drücken,
dann vergisst er die Karte.
Genau, also man hat hier vorne,
kannst du das Ding starten, stoppen.
Man kann, ganz, ganz nützlich ist,
man kann, ähm,
Areas definieren.
Hab ich jetzt hier eingestellt.
Äh, unter der Treppe unten
Wohnzimmer, äh,
Flur unten, Schlafzimmer,
Küche, Bad, Bad oben, äh,
oben Flur, oben Wohnzimmer
und oben Schlafzimmer.
Und, nachdem der ja
eine Karte drin hat,
klickt man dann eins davon an
und er fährt halt direkt hin.
Wie kommt er die verschiedenen
Stockwerke gar nicht? Tragen.
Da hab ich doch nix.
Den musst du tragen.
Hier, genau, hier kann man die
unterschiedlichen Zonen einstellen.
Äh, hier kann man auch, wenn man, wenn man will,
auf dem Tablet das Ding manuell controlen.
Ah, also man kann
den mit dem Tablet wie eine Fernsteuerung durch die Wohnung
fahren. Ja, und hier hat man irgendwie
irgendwelche Settings.
Also das ist ganz, ganz nettes Webinterface,
ja. Oh.
Ich glaub, jetzt hab ich ihn
irgendwohin geschickt.
Okay, was auch immer, ich mach jetzt mal zu.
Ja.
Und das ist nämlich
der Grund, warum ich einen zweiten will.
Das ist ein Grund, warum ich einen zweiten will.
Ich will nämlich einen für oben
und einen für unten haben.
Weil das Ding spackt immer rum,
wenn man es hochhebt und Knöpfe drückt
und, äh, dann merkt's, dass es nicht
mehr im richtigen Stockwerk ist und dann
vergisst es die Map und baut die Map neu auf
und so. Das ist, das ist ziemlich blöd.
Und ich hab mir gedacht, eigentlich hab ich auch gar
keinen Bock, den Kram hoch und runter
zu tragen, sondern, ähm,
ich kauf mir einfach einen zweiten. Allerdings,
ich kauf mir keinen zweiten
für 420 Euro. Das seh ich nicht
ein. Ich muss jetzt mal nachgucken, was ich dafür bezahlt
hab. Ich bilde mir einen 250
oder sowas. Das war
richtig günstig, deswegen hab ich den damals auch
bestellt. Äh,
S50
Roborock
Ach nee,
fuck, den hab ich bei Alternate bestellt. Ich kann jetzt
gar nicht nachgucken. Äh, bestellste
einmal was nicht bei Amazon, schon
kannst du nicht mal nachgucken.
Äh, für ein Microcontroller, kann man da
ein Arduino Starterkit empfehlen? Ja, ich würd
gar kein Arduino nehmen.
Ich würd mir nen,
dieser Kack-Handyhalter.
Ich muss den löschen aus der History.
Ich komm immer auf diesen dämlichen Handyhalter
raus, wenn ich auf Amazon
gehe.
Äh, ich würd gar keinen, gar keinen empfehlen.
Als Einstieg ist eigentlich, ähm,
sowas
hier nicht schlecht.
Rein zum, rein zum, rein zum Basteln
ist das hier ganz praktisch.
Wobei das viel, viel zu teuer ist,
grade bei Amazon, wie ich sehe.
Ähm, normalerweise
kriegst du ein Board für 4 Euro oder sowas, oder du
holst dir ne,
ja, hier, 5 Stück 20 Euro.
Ähm, die sind ein bisschen
teuer grade auf Amazon.
Aber es geht. Also ich würd mir nen
ESP32 oder nen ESP
2866 holen. Das ist zwar
kein Original-Arduino,
aber das ist Arduino-kompatibel.
Echt, geht das?
Shift entfernen.
Okay.
Ja, aber...
Es bleibt immer noch im...
Oder auch nicht.
Ach, vielleicht muss ich das nicht in der
anonymen Session machen.
Vielleicht hat er's jetzt schon gelöscht.
Ja, hab ich doch. Warst du grad,
warst du grad nicht da? Ich hab grad das
Webinterface von meinem Staubsauger-Roboter gezeigt.
Verlauf löschen.
Du warst ab...
Ja, ich kann's dir nochmal zeigen.
Kann's dir nochmal zeigen.
Äh, was war das?
122168, 1.
107?
Ich hab's vergessen.
Oh, ach, 60, 107
war's, ne? 60,
genau.
Da, da hast du die Übersicht.
Ach ja, was auch noch ganz cool ist,
ähm, man kann einstellen,
wie stark er saugen soll und
der hat nen...
nen Teppichmodus,
wo man einstellen kann, dass er
Teppiche stärker saugt.
Das ist wirklich ganz cool.
Es gibt ein deutsches Sprachpaket, hab ich eben noch gar nicht
erzählt. Es gibt ein deutsches Sprachpaket,
weil vor allem Grills sind da ja sehr
wählerig.
Wenn das Ding Englisch redet, sagen wir, oh nö, das wär doof.
Wenn das Ding Deutsch redet, und sagt er, wenn du auf
Feind drückst, sagt er, hallo, hier bin ich.
Hallo, hier bin ich. Hallo, hier bin ich.
Also,
sagt er halt, ne, wenn du das deutsche
Sprachpaket drauf machst.
Also, Nico, ich kann dir nur empfehlen, flash das Ding.
Du brauchst ein Raspberry Pi mit WLAN dazu.
Es ist aber relativ easy.
Und ich würde nicht
Firmware-Aktualisierung machen.
Ich würde auf keinen Fall die Firmware-Aktualisierung
machen, weil die sind gerade dabei,
die Sachen zu blocken.
Mit Custom Firmware.
Also auf keinen Fall
Firmware-Update machen.
Aber du brauchst ein Raspberry Pi mit WLAN.
Unbedingt, zwingend.
Ansonsten ist die Anleitung hier eigentlich ganz gut.
Was ich gemacht hab, ist,
ich verwende nicht das letzte Release,
sondern ich verwende das, was im Master
drin ist. Der kann ein paar mehr Sachen.
Der hat zum Beispiel im Webinterface drin,
dass du direkt im Webinterface
Regionen anlegen kannst, wo der Roboter
hinfahren soll. Wann kommt
ein neues Video? Wenn ich Spock auf
YouTube hab.
Pass mal auf, falls noch einer was wissen will nachher.
So.
Ja. Also, wer hatte
noch mal? Der ZargorNet hat
gefragt. Also, ich würde
einen ESP2866 oder einen ESP32
empfehlen, um mit
Microcontroller-Zeug anzufangen. Super easy
zu programmieren. Arduino
kompatibel. Hat USB und
alles schon Onboard. Das heißt, du brauchst auch keinen
Programmieradapter mehr oder
irgendwas. Und,
was finde ich jetzt auch ein ganz guter Vorteil
ist,
die ESP sind 3,3 Volt
und die meisten Sensoren sind auch
3,3 Volt.
Arduino ist 5 Volt.
Hey, etwas off-topic, aber
welches Rack hast du?
Ähm, ich hatte mir damals
bei Rackmagic oder so
was gekauft.
Der Shop sieht aus wie 1995.
Ähm,
ich hatte mir bei denen was kleines gekauft.
Ich glaube das da.
Ne, meins hat 14
Höheneinheiten.
Zwölf? Ne, zwölf Höheneinheiten.
Irgendwas von denen hatte ich.
Allerdings ein fertiges Rack
und nicht so ein, so ein, so ein
Raster, ja.
Raster habe ich.
Allerdings war das damals gefühlt
auch nicht so teuer. Irgendwie ist alles viel teurer
geworden. Also, man kann richtig viel Geld
sparen, wenn man sich ein Rack sucht.
Ich hatte die Antwort, ich wollte ein besonders
kleines Rack. Also, ich wollte
eins, was nicht so tief ist.
Das ist nämlich nur 144,
äh, 440 Millimeter, also
44 Zentimeter tief.
Lassen sich mit der Custom Firma im Roborock
die Fall Detection Sensoren abschalten?
Ich glaube nicht.
Wahrscheinlich musst du das manuell machen. Ich könnte mir
vorstellen, dass es an sich geht.
An einem Chatbot machst du heute
nicht weiter. Vielleicht am Ende
noch ein bisschen was. Allerdings funktioniert das Chatbot
jetzt ziemlich gut. Sogar mit,
sogar mit Emotes.
Wobei das nicht an mir liegt, dass es mit Emotes
funktioniert. Allerdings man kann bei
Racks relativ viel Geld sparen,
wenn man keine Sonderwünsche hat,
in Form von, soll nur 44 Zentimeter
tief sein, soll nur so und so hoch sein.
Gebrauchte Racks sind
relativ günstig, weil wenn
einer einen Rack loswerden will, dann
will er da meistens nicht viel für haben.
Wenn man nach gebrauchten Racks guckt.
Und wenn man
was kompaktes haben will, wo es sich auch
zu lohnen schaut, sind Audio Racks.
Audio Racks sehen halt nicht so
servertechnisch aus,
allerdings sind das auch 19 Zoll Racks,
wo man auch Sachen reinstellen kann.
Sehen halt nicht so servermäßig aus, aber ich meine,
wen juckt die Optik? Das ist ein Gestell.
Also mit Audio Racks kann man auch ein bisschen was sparen.
So.
Dann gucken wir mal, was unser Pepega-Bot macht.
Ich muss die Fragen abhaken, sonst komme ich überhaupt nicht
hinterher.
Haben wir beantwortet? Haben wir beantwortet?
Haben wir...
Haben wir
beantwortet?
Kann man den Schaubsauger in Home Assistant
integrieren? Ja, klar.
Kannste machen.
Ähm...
Wieso der sich nicht automatisch refresht?
Weil ich Refresh auf 0 gestellt habe.
Kann man den Staubsauger zufällig in Home...
Kann man machen, habe ich schon gesagt.
Der flecht seine Freunde. Na gut.
Kannste Steckdosenleiste...
Kannste bei der
Steckdosenleiste die einzelnen Ports schalten
oder alle auf einmal? Jeden einzelnen
Port kann ich schalten, inklusive USB.
Allerdings die USB-Charger
kann ich nur alle oder keinen
ein- und ausschalten.
In der Steckdosenleiste habe ich 5 Schalter.
Für 4 Geräte
und die 4 USB-Ports.
Kannste mir sagen,
wie ich im Home Assistant
sagen soll, welchen DNS-Server
er fest benutzen soll? Der nimmt
normalerweise den, den du...
Was hast du?
Hast du Home Assistant... Hast du die HASS-IO
Geschichte? Oder hast du
Linux mit drauf
installiert? Oder HASS-IO
auf Linux? Ach, du hast
HASS-OS. Stimmt. Hast ja gerade einen Link gepostet.
Habe ich noch nicht verwendet.
Weiß ich nicht.
Replace the following configuration. Wieso steht doch da?
Oder meinst du, wo die Datei ist,
wo man das replacen muss?
Ich habe als Staubsauger-Roboter
habe ich einen Roborock
S50.
Ich kenne das OS nicht. Ich weiß nicht, welche
Datei das ist. Allerdings...
Na hier.
config-network
my-network
slash config slash network
my-network. In dieser Datei.
Wo musst du das editieren?
config-network my-network
Keine Endung.
Einfach ein File, was my-network heißt.
Gar keine Endung.
Endung ist eh so ein komisches Windows-Konzept.
Also unter Linux gibt es sau viele
Files, die keine Endung haben.
Die meisten Files haben eigentlich keine Endung.
Haben wir beantwortet?
Hattest du mal Kontakt mit P-Tweeten?
Ne.
Hast du smarte Lampen?
Ich habe eine im Einsatz.
Und ich habe ein paar
Relays
für Schalter.
Ansonsten bin ich kein allzu großer Fan
von
von smarten Lampen.
Das habe ich auch schon öfters erzählt im Stream.
Deswegen erzähle ich das nochmal ganz kurz.
Du hast das Problem, wenn du
smarte Lampen hast, dass du die immer noch
an der Lampe dran hast, die du mit dem Lichtschalter schalten kannst.
Und wenn du mit dem Lichtschalter ausschaltest,
ist die smarte Lampe nicht mehr smart.
Deswegen ist es
viel intelligenter, finde ich.
Ich bin ja viel big brainiger.
Also viel mehr 900 IQ mäßig.
Das war jetzt auch wieder
Twitch-Chat ohne Ende.
Wenn du die
Lichtschalter smart machst und nicht die Lampe.
Lichtschalter ausbauen
ist auch keine Alternative.
Lichtschalter ausbauen bedeutet, man kann die Lampe
nicht mal an einem Schalter ein- und ausschalten.
Und du willst ja oftmals einfach in den
Raum reingehen,
Lichtschalter drücken und Licht soll
angehen. Du willst nicht erst
suchen, wo dein Tablet ist, um das Licht
einzuschalten. Du willst beides machen können.
Du willst Zugriff von deinem Tablet auf die
Lichtsteuerung haben. Du willst, dass deine
Heimautomatisierung auf deine Lichtsteuerung zugreifen kann.
Und du willst immer noch, wenn du auf
einen Kackschalter an der Wand drückst,
was das Licht angeht.
Deswegen kann ich als
Relay für
als Relay für
Lichtschalter oder Relay für Lampen kann ich
eigentlich nur das hier empfehlen. Das ist ziemlich gut.
Shelly One.
Das
Beste an dem Ding ist,
na gut, dass da Open Source dahinten dran steht, ist egal.
Man kann es entweder mit Tasmota flashen
oder aber man kann es
einfach auch mit einer Stock-Firmware verwenden,
die keinerlei Cloud-Anbindung
braucht. Die Domain
ist absolut next level.
Also bei Shelly haben jetzt nicht so die
aller cleversten Leute dran gesessen, weil
eines der Hauptverkaufsargumente
für diese Shelly-Dinger,
für diese Shelly-Software, äh für
diese Shelly-Relays, ist,
eben, dass sie keine
Cloud brauchen. Da ist es
natürlich wahnsinnig big brain, seine
Domain shelly.cloud zu nennen.
Also wie gesagt, das Hauptverkaufsargument ist,
die Dinger brauchen keine Cloud.
Das ist schon ein bisschen dämlich,
ja. Aber
okay. Man kann sie
connecten mit der Shelly-Cloud, ja.
Aber das
Hauptverkaufsargument schlechthin von den Dingern
ist, dass sie keine Cloud-Anbindung brauchen.
Hast du ein Bild von deinem Setup?
Ne, habe ich nicht. Außerdem ist es
mein Setup auch ziemlich
im Haus verteilt.
Ist halt Smart Home.
Da gibt es halt kein Bild von einer Sache.
Okay.
Ähm, wo sind wir denn
jetzt eigentlich stehen geblieben?
Wir haben jetzt ja viel, viel, viel erzählt.
Äh, sollte man für,
übrigens Leute, ähm, es wäre gut,
wenn ihr Fragen habt, die ich, ähm,
wo ich was zu sagen soll,
schreibt adwublos dazu, weil dann
kriegt es mein Fragentool mit.
Da kann ich nichts mehr übersehen.
Wenn ihr nicht adwublos dabei schreibt,
dann muss ich zufällig gerade in Chat gucken,
dass ich es sehe. Nur wenn da adwublos
irgendwo in der Frage steht, dann
taucht es hier auf und es ist gelockt.
Ähm, sollte man für
Smart Home ein eigenes
abgeschottetes Subnetz machen?
Ja, ähm,
man sollte mehrere
abgeschottete Subnetz machen.
Also,
soll
ich mal kurz aufmalen, wie ich das
empfehlen würde, wie man
sein Netzwerk daheim einrichten sollte,
wenn man, also mit und
ohne Smart Home.
Ähm,
also was ich machen würde,
ist folgendes, ähm,
äh, wenn Rollladen
vorhanden, schon automatisiert oder
vorzuautomatisieren, ja,
beides. Ich hab
so Plastik
Rollläden von
Somfy heißen die, glaube
ich, und ich hab noch so welche,
so dicke aus Holz.
Ähm,
die Somfy-Dinger hab ich schon
automatisiert.
Die gehen über,
Alter, war das,
war das gerade Erdbeben oder was?
Es hat gerade voll gewackelt im Haus.
Was war das denn?
Ist auch kein Zug vorbeigefahren.
Moment.
Ne, ohne Scheiß, ich meine, es war gerade
ein schlimmes Erdbeben, es hat voll gewackelt gerade.
Wartet mal kurz.
Hat sich erledigt.
Katze umgefallen, also dick
ist die auch noch nicht.
Ich meine, die Katze ist zwar dick,
aber nicht so dick.
Ah.
Okay, ähm,
genau, ich wollte mein Netzwerk aufmalen und noch ganz schnell
was zu den Rollos sagen.
Also die Somfy-Dinger hab ich
aktuali-, äh, hab ich, ähm,
automatisiert. Die sind relativ
easy gewesen mit,
also ganz normalem RF-Funk.
Megahertz ist das, glaub ich, gewesen.
Ist recht einfach gewesen.
Ähm, die
Holzrollos
hab ich ein Prototyp hier am Start,
um das zu automatisieren.
Und zwar hab ich einen,
hab ich das hier gekauft,
Amazon.
Zeig dir, was ich gekauft hab.
Nicht, com.
De.
Äh, Duofan.
So ein Ding.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das der ist.
Irgendeiner mit,
irgendeinen davon
hab ich gekauft,
weil der hat ne,
auf Github,
auf Github gibt es eine Library
für das Ding.
Natürlich nicht offiziell vom Hersteller, ne, ist klar.
Hab ich gefunden und
man muss sich einfach nur den
Duofan-USB-Stick kaufen,
was irgendwie 30 Euro oder so das teilt.
Ähm, und damit
mit dem USB-Stick,
wenn man, wenn man ihn irgendwie findet,
ähm, mit diesem USB-Stick,
und, pff, Alter,
warum ist der Scheiß alles so teuer geworden,
äh? Okay, es wird schon billiger.
Okay, 30 Euro waren übertrieben.
40 Euro, 40, 50 Euro.
So, und das kann man mit der Library
und dem passenden USB-Stick,
kann man diesen Gurtwickler steuern.
Und der macht, glaub ich, bis zu 30 Kilo.
Braucht natürlich den
Stromanschluss.
Und damit, da hab ich aber nur ein Prototyp am Start gerade.
Hab ich noch nicht im Haus eingebaut.
Ähm, okay.
Netzwerk wollte ich mal. Also,
äh, wir machen erst mal, wie ich Netzwerk daheim
einteilen würde.
Wird irgendwas gemacht heute?
Ich, äh, wollte eigentlich in China einkaufen
und irgendwie sind wir jetzt bei Gott und der Welt
von Technikkrams wieder gelandet.
Ähm,
eigentlich hatte ich vor, in China einzukaufen,
dann ein bisschen ESP32 Multithreading zu programmieren.
Also, Netzwerkmäßig
würde ich folgendermaßen machen. Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Machen wir so einen Kringel oder so, hm?
Oder haben die schönere Symbole
für Netzwerk?
Ein Firewall-Symbol
kommt in den Router. Ein Router!
Ein Router-Symbol brauchen wir noch.
Hier.
Da routet er.
Er routet, der Router.
So.
Also, was ich machen würde ist,
also, was meine grundsätzliche Frage ist,
wenn man, äh, daheim Netzwerk
betreibt, will man
irgendwas von außen verwenden?
Kennst du gute
Einfach-Steckdosen,
die per Webinterface... Nee.
Ich kenne nur die Steckdosenleiste,
die sich per Webinterface
steuern lässt.
Du kannst ja aber, wenn du
eine richtig gute
Steckdosenleiste haben willst,
was hältst du von einer Z-Wave-Steckdosenleiste?
Kostet 29 Euro.
Da brauchst du aber halt einen Z-Wave-Stick
und ein System,
was Z-Wave kann. Das ist wahrscheinlich...
Also, wenn du es wirklich per Webinterface willst,
eine einfache Steckdosenleiste,
die du per Webinterface flashen kannst,
ist das nichts zu einem.
Das könnten wir echt mal machen.
Twitch Plays Heimautomatisierung.
Ich überlasse euch einfach,
ich überlasse dem Twitch Chat einfach mal
einen Tag mal
meine Heimautomatisierung.
Mal gucken, was der Twitch Chat macht.
Ja, in Sonoff kann man sich holen,
allerdings ist in Sonoff keine
Steckdosenleiste, so wirklich, sondern...
Oder keine Steckdose.
Bei Sonoff, da musst du ja wirklich das Kabel
aufschneiden und reinmachen.
Also einfach reinstecken und so ist da nicht.
Oh, ist explodiert.
Okay, also Netzwerk.
Das erste, was man sich fragen muss, wir machen jetzt mal hier.
Internet.
Und das machen wir rot.
Weil Internet ist böse.
So. Das erste, was man sich fragen muss,
wenn das hier Internet ist hier
und das hier Router, der routet,
möchte man
irgendwas von dem, was hier dahinter ist,
das hier hinter machen wir mal
intern,
das teilen wir gleich noch auf,
möchte man in irgendeiner Art und Weise
von da was da verwenden.
Ne?
Also von intern nach extern ist ja kein Problem.
Steckerleiste, Ausrufezeichen
Steckerleiste ist der richtige,
richtige Command.
Ähm...
Wenn man vom Internet intern hin
zugreifen will, macht es das ein bisschen komplizierter.
Da muss man...
Da muss man sich ein bisschen mehr Gedanken machen.
Ähm...
Ja, VPN ist ja
im Endeffekt dann ein eigenes Netz.
Was sei denn,
man nimmt das interne Netz mit.
Würde ich aber nicht machen.
Ich würde VPN immer in ein eigenes Netz verfrachten.
Da kann man nämlich auch
viel besser den Zugriff steuern.
Na, sonst klaut einmal einer das Handy
und hat gleich Zugriff irgendwie aufs ganze Haus.
Also ich würde
mit VPN schon. Okay, gehen wir mal von aus.
Man möchte per VPN von
aus... äh, wir machen erst mal
den, ähm...
den, den, den einfachsten Fall.
So, man hat ne,
man hat ne FRITZ!Box, wobei, mit ner FRITZ!Box
kommste halt leider nicht, kommste halt nicht leider weit,
weil das einzige, was du mit ner FRITZ!Box machen
kannst, ist, ähm...
intern,
WLAN, das ist das
gleiche Netz und,
ähm...
Gast-WLAN. Das ist das Einzige, was
du mit ner FRITZ!Box machen kannst, ohne
großartige... Viel mehr kannst du mit ner
FRITZ!Box nicht einstellen. Da hast du, da hast du nicht
so viel Option. So,
ähm, das heißt, ich würde schon mal gucken,
dass man... Die FRITZ!Box ist, ist, ist...
ist ein super ein super multifunktions kommunikationsgerät ja da kann man nichts
zu sagen die fritzbox ist toll die kann deckt die kann dsl eine wahl kabel modem einwahl also
für sowas ist die super da würde ich dafür verwenden allerdings als router oder firewall
ist die fritzbox nicht so toll deswegen ist es nicht verkehrt man stellt sich noch einen
router hinten dran das ist generell das erste was ich machen würde ich würde mir irgendwie
den günstigen mikrotik router kaufen oder aber pfz wie einer gerade im chat geschrieben hat
oder ip cop oder sowas wenn man noch einen alten rechner hat am einfachsten dürfte es allerdings
sein wenn man nicht viel machen will und man sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigen will da geht es
ja nämlich letztendlich darum weil umsonst ist das insofern nicht zeiteinsatz braucht das schon ja
fritzbox anstöpseln ein paar hinzubekommen
häkchen machen kann jeder aber das ordentlich machen kann man kann nicht jeder so also das
erste was ich machen würde ich würde mir einen zusätzlichen router kaufen er kommt dann hinter
die fritzbox die fritzbox macht genau macht macht deckt und macht internet einwahl und das
was im großen und ganzen schon man kann sich überlegen ob man die fritzbox nicht vielleicht
auch vpn machen lässt allerdings das würde ich eigentlich würde ich das alles den hier
machen lassen also das erste was ich mir kaufen würde und da ist man schon auf einem ziemlich guten
weg ist ein ordentlicher ein ordentlicher router wenn man sich selbst bauen will würde ich eine
mikrotik kiste empfehlen router os ist nicht das einfachste ich zeige euch mal wie das webinterface
aussieht was man dann so kriegt wir sind übrigens nicht teuer ich empfehle ja immer den hier als
einsteiger router empfehle ich immer den den hex poe ist nicht teuer 50 euro das sind die falschen
übrigens irgendwie 60 euro oder so also ich würde ich würde den hex poe nehmen dass das eigentlich
ziemlich gut an ordentliche cpu drin du hast 1 2 3 4 5 port und sogar noch ein fsp port falls man
das jemals brauchen sollte also den kann man empfehlen das ist wirklich super ding so und
wenn man auf den auf den auf den router drauf geht das ist nicht mein router das ist die offizielle
demo von von mikrotik das ist die offizielle demo von von mikrotik das ist die offizielle demo von von mikrotik
dann wird man erst mal erschlagen mit allen möglichen optionen man muss ich ein paar
tutorials angucken aber im prinzip ist der kram nicht so schwierig wenn man nicht abgedrehte
sachen machen will ja wenn man anfängt irgendwie zu sagen hey ich habe zwei router daheim und möchte
ospf machen warum auch immer da wird es ein bisschen komplizierter aber die normalen sachen
dhcp server netze anlegen oder eben auch ein paar firewall regel anlegen ist nicht so schwierig auch
man braucht man muss ich bloß ein bisschen mit beschäftigen also das ist das erste was ich machen
würde es ich bin noch ordentlichen router kaufen dann würde ich ein internes netzwerk definieren
wir machen die ip-kopf haben die haben nämlich rot blau grün internes netzwerk h mines bei mir
das ist kein wla das ist kabel das ist ein internes netzwerk das geht nur dass kommtnnn
kommnnd cucumber carbon article vide oder risiken grundnapalm atme rehabilitation AI war zwei
Das hier, da ist nochmal ein Switch dazwischen oder so, was auch immer, weil mit einem Port kommt man ja wahrscheinlich nicht aus.
Das geht an einen Port hier dran, das ist intern das Netzwerk und fertig.
Wer kennt das nicht, OSPF im Heimbereich, deswegen habe ich es ja auch gerade so aus Spaß gesagt, das macht ja kein Mensch.
Genau, und das ist nur Kabel.
Das mache ich grün an der Stelle, weil das wirklich das sensibelste Netz ist, was man hat.
Da ist das interne NAS dran, da ist die Desktop-Rechner dran, da ist quasi so das Zeugs dran, wo die sensibelsten Sachen drauf liegen.
Deswegen ist das ein Ding, wo auch kein WLAN direkt reinkommt, sondern Kabel, vielleicht noch ein Switch, weil ich meine, mit einem Port wird man nicht hinkommen.
Kabel aus dem MikroTik-Router raus, an den Switch dran und da kann man dann alles mögliche anschließen.
Ja, Drucker intern.
Desktop-Rechner intern, ich habe das Shield-TV noch beispielsweise dran, das ist bei mir auch intern.
Alles interne, also das ist quasi das sicherste Netz.
Dementsprechend richtet man auch gleichermaßen noch eine Firewall-Regel rein, dass dieses Netz ohne weitere Freischaltung immer und überall hin darf.
Das ist auch quasi das Netz, von dem ihr dann alles andere administrieren könnt.
Da könnt ihr euch auch nicht mehr aussperren, könnt einfach sagen, das interne Netz, dem vertraue ich.
Dann hat man auch nur dran, wenn man im Haus ist und dort an den Netzwerk-Ports rankommt.
Wir reden jetzt mal nicht von Port-Security oder sowas, das ist im Heimbereich alles viel zu Overkill.
Man muss es nicht total übertreiben.
Also man könnte, man könnte das machen.
Man könnte beispielsweise sagen, also wenn man einen ordentlichen Switch hat oder einen ordentlichen Router, wobei man braucht einen Switch, der hat zu wenig Ports,
kann man so Dinge machen wie, der Client muss sich erstmal authentifizieren, dass der Netzwerk-Port funktioniert oder die MAC-Adresse muss stimmen.
Aber das ist Overkill, das macht eigentlich keiner daheim.
Oder hat jemand Port-Security bei euch im Heimbereich?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Sergeant Blackburn, beantworte ich alles noch heute?
Ich habe jetzt ja hier mein schönes PPGa-Tool, wo alle Fragen drin geloggt sind.
Das heißt, ich vergesse auch nichts.
Genau, das würde ich machen zuerst.
Interesse-Netzwerk, wichtig.
Okay, weiter.
Als nächstes würde ich ein WLAN, ein, ein, ähm, nennen wir es mal, nennen wir es mal irgendwie,
wie?
User-WLAN, oder, oder, wie auch immer.
Ähm, das ist, das ist das normale WLAN, was man so kennt.
Ähm, das, da kommen Tablets rein, da kommen Smartphones rein, da kommt vielleicht der smarte Fernseher rein, falls man den da reinhängen will,
wobei, da komme ich gleich dazu, würde ich nicht unbedingt machen.
Übrigens, ich fange jetzt hier nicht an mit WLANs oder sowas.
Ich male mal nur, wie logisch von oben betrachtet die Trennung aussehen würde.
Okay.
Ob man die Dinger jetzt tatsächlich an den eigenen Port jeweils dranhängt, oder ob man das über WLANs macht, das ist ja dann im Endeffekt ein bisschen, ist ja dann eigentlich egal.
Ähm, so, das würde ich, so, das ist so das Basic-Setup, was ich immer machen würde.
Ich würde das hier nicht miteinander verbinden.
Ich, ich würde sagen, immer sagen, es gibt ein safes, internes Netzwerk.
Da kommt nur Ports dran, äh, da kommen nur Kabel dran.
Und es gibt ein halbwegs sicheres, normales WLAN.
Da kommen auch keine in dieses WLAN.
Da kommen auch keine Leute rein.
Denen gibt man auch keinen Leuten den Zugang, wo man denen mal nicht, äh, nicht traut.
Aber trotzdem, sollte man mal irgendwie jemandem den Zugang gegeben haben, oder was auch immer, derjenige hat schon mal keinen Zugang auf meine intern sensiblen Sachen.
Weil Zugriff von hier nach hier ist nicht.
Zugriff von hier nach hier ist kein Problem.
Und Zugriff von WLAN nach Internet ist auch okay.
Ähm, dann, wenn man öfters geltet, dann ist das auch okay.
Und wenn man öfters geltet, dann ist das auch okay.
Wenn man öfters geltet hat, es gibt ja Leute, die sind so sozial und haben manchmal Leute bei sich.
Also ich nicht, aber gibt's ja.
Dann würde ich noch ein, ähm, nennen wir es mal Gäste-WLAN machen, beziehungsweise man könnte auch schon sowas, ich nenne es mal Gäste-WLAN-Schrägschräg Internet of Things-WLAN.
Ähm, man kann sich dann überlegen, ob man, ob man wirklich noch ein drittes machen möchte.
Also ich habe drei WLANs.
Ähm, drei WLANs ist bei mir nicht drei unterschiedliche Access Points.
sondern iNexus Points mit drei WLAN-IDs und WLANs drunter.
So, das würde ich machen und der ist schon ein bisschen unsicherer, das Ganze.
Hier kann man den Zugang Gästen geben und hier kann man auch seine ganzen IoT-Devices reinhängen.
Ja, Sys0, du hast recht, ich würde es auch nicht so machen.
Das machen wir aber in der Reihe nach jetzt. Ich würde es auch nicht so machen.
Aber wenn man es nicht total übertreiben will, kann man das so machen.
Ich würde allerdings IoT und Gäste auch trennen.
Wobei, ich habe kein Gäste-WLAN, weil ihr wisst ja, ich bin Keller-Admin, der hat keine Freunde, da kommen auch keine Leute vorbei.
Dafür bin ich dieses Jahr erstaunlich braun. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das herkommt.
Das ist eigentlich ausgeschlossen, ey.
Warum habe ich überhaupt Farbe?
Genau, also bei mir ist das nicht so, aber wir nennen es mal Gäste, Gäste, IoT, WLAN.
Hier kann man dann zum Beispiel die geflashte Steckdosenleiste reinhängen oder sowas.
Allerdings habe ich es ein bisschen anders.
Ich habe das WLAN und ich habe noch einen, weil ich auch kein Gäste-WLAN habe, ich habe einen China-WLAN.
Da ist zum Beispiel alle möglichen China-Dinger drin, die ich nicht flashen kann und denen ich nicht so ganz traue.
Und das China-WLAN, das kommt nirgendwo hin.
China-WLAN darf nicht ins Internet.
China-WLAN darf nicht ins User-WLAN und China-WLAN darf schon gar nicht ins interne Netzwerk.
Internes Netzwerk darf ins China-WLAN, User-WLAN darf auch ins China-WLAN, allerdings ansonsten nichts.
So, wenn man das trennt, könnte man auch sagen, Gäste-WLAN, China-WLAN.
Wir machen die WLANs mal ein bisschen kleiner.
China-WLAN, Gäste-WLAN.
China-WLAN.
So.
So ungefähr sieht das bei mir aus.
Ups.
Ja, und ich habe noch einen Test-WLAN offen, wo ich immer mal wieder ein bisschen drin rumspiele.
Aber so könnte man das im Prinzip machen.
Es sieht kompliziert aus, man braucht dafür gar nicht so viele Geräte.
Wenn man nämlich sich ordentliche Geräte kauft, also ordentliche Access-Points bzw. ordentliche Router, kann man das alles mit diesen Geräten machen.
Man braucht keine drei Access-Points, ja.
Oder sonst was.
Man braucht einen ordentlichen Access-Point, der mehrere...
...WLANs aufmachen kann.
Das ist alles.
Und der WLANs kann.
Ähm, so.
Und wenn man per VPN drauf zugreifen will, dann würde ich noch sowas hier machen.
Äh.
Open VPN.
Open VPN ist auch ein eigenes Netz, das ist dann hier irgendwie so dazwischen.
Ähm.
Da kann man sich überlegen, wo das hin darf, was man haben will.
Ich habe drei SSIDs, genau, richtig.
So, und der Zugriff ist folgendermaßen.
Das China-WLAN ist übrigens rot, genauso rot wie das Internet.
Das darf nirgends wohin.
Oh, das war orange.
Ich meine, es ist immerhin noch...
Ja, das ist rot.
So.
Ähm.
Was alles das hier gemeinsam hat, ist...
Es darf nicht in das interne Netzwerk.
Ich finde, das ist eigentlich die wichtigste Regel.
Sollte es irgendwie doch mal erforderlich sein, dass man ins interne Netzwerk muss.
Zum Beispiel, weil man sich per OpenVPN verbunden hat.
Und auf das interne NAS zugreifen will.
Da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten, was man machen kann.
Ähm.
Man muss sich überlegen, sind das so sensible Daten, dass die ins interne Netzwerk gehören?
Vielleicht hat man ja irgendeine Kiste im WLAN.
Wo man, oder nicht im WLAN, also in diesem Netz drin.
Das muss ja nicht zwangsläufig wirklich WLAN sein, nur weil es das WLAN-Netz ist.
Ähm.
Dass man die vielleicht da reinlegen kann.
Und wenn man sagt, okay, man muss unbedingt von OpenVPN auf das...
...interne Netzwerk zugreifen.
Dann würde ich auf keinen Fall sagen, OpenVPN darf auf das interne Netzwerk zugreifen.
Ähm.
Sondern, ich würde genau diese eine Sache freischalten.
Man kann da noch, man kann da beliebige Hürden noch einbauen.
Ja, man könnte noch irgendwie eine Reverse-Proxy dazwischen stellen.
Oder was auch immer.
Wo man sich nochmal authentifizieren muss.
Allerdings prinzipiell würde ich dann nur diese eine Sache freischalten.
Dann würde ich halt sagen, okay.
Ich schalte frei von OpenVPN auf...
...mein internes NAS.
Allerdings dann auch nur auf dem einen Port, den ich für Datenshare brauche.
Wenn ich das wirklich haben will.
So würde ich das machen.
So oder so ähnlich ist es bei mir daheim auch gemacht.
Äh, einen VPN-Anbieter, den ich ans Herz legen kann.
Ich benutze keine VPN-Anbieter.
Einziger VPN-Anbieter bin ich selber, wenn ich mich daheim einwählen will.
Wo sitzt der Pi-Hall, den du hast?
Ähm, den habe ich gerade nicht.
Den habe ich nicht mehr.
Äh.
Und wenn ich ihn, wenn ich ihn hätte, würde er da sitzen.
Nämlich genau aus dem Grund, den ich gerade erklärt habe.
Der sitzt da, weil man kann hiervon drauf, man kann hiervon drauf und man kann hiervon drauf.
Würde der da stehen, könnte ich aus dem WLAN nicht drauf.
Oder man müsste es hier drüber irgendwie so proxien.
Ähm.
Also der würde hier stehen, wenn ich einen hätte.
Ich habe aber keinen mehr.
Da bringt mir leider nichts.
Weil Twitch kannst du nicht mehr blocken.
YouTube kannst du nicht mehr richtig blocken.
Ja.
Und wenn man dadurch, dass man das China-WLAN hat, kann man auch irgendwelche komischen China-Cloud-Dinger bei sich daheim im Netzwerk betreiben.
Ähm.
Ohne, dass man Angst haben muss, dass die Dinger irgendwas treiben.
Weil in diesem Netzwerk, und es ist wichtig, Leute.
Denkt dran.
Ähm.
Wenn ihr so ein Netzwerk macht und blockiert den Zugriff, dann blockiert alles.
Ja.
Lasst am besten die Ni-Any standardmäßig drin für dieses Netz.
Also man sollte ja seine Firewall eh so einstellen, dass die Fault-Regel ist.
Also ist alles, alles verbieten, was nicht erlaubt ist.
Umgedrehter Fall finde ich ein bisschen sinnlos.
Ähm.
Man kann natürlich eine Firewall auch machen.
Okay.
Man verbietet es explizit, ansonsten ist es erlaubt.
Aber normalerweise machst du das so, du verwirfst alles, was nicht explizit erlaubt ist.
Und ähm.
Denkt dran, ihr müsst wirklich darauf versorgen, das Ding darf nirgendwo hin.
Das heißt, das Ding darf auch nicht ins Internet pingen oder so.
Und das China-Ding darf auch nicht ins, das darf auch kein DNS ins Internet machen.
Das darf nichts.
Das darf in seinem eigenen Netzwerk rumgammeln.
Und was ihr dann auch noch macht ist, ihr schaltet auf eurem, auf eurem, ähm.
Auf eurem Access-Point schaltet ihr noch Client-Isolation an.
Isolation, Isolation, Isolation.
Das bedeutet, dass sogar in diesem WLAN selbst die Geräte nicht mal miteinander reden dürfen.
Ah.
Und dann ist es vorbei.
Dann haben die China-Dinger keine Chance mehr.
Frage beantwortet.
Ähm.
Wer hat das mit Netzwerk 1 gefragt?
Sehe ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Aber ich hoffe, die Frage ist beantwortet.
Hallo, Mavid49.
Einfach keine China-Dinger kaufen, ja, das ist keine Option.
Äh, smarte Lampen habe ich beantwortet, Bild habe ich auch beantwortet.
Funktioniert es?
Was auch immer.
Ähm.
Äh, ich könnte mir das Bild mal speichern.
Das brauchen wir bestimmt öfters mal.
Don't load.
Ähm.
Roller an, habe ich auch beantwortet.
Ja und ne, ich muss erst überlegen, wie ich das mache.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie viele Leute das auf YouTube interessiert, wenn ich was über Heimautomatisierung labere.
Wieso Chrome und Chromium?
Weil ich, ich habe Chrome, Chromium, Firefox, ich habe so ziemlich alles drauf an Browser, was es gibt.
Aber beantwortet.
Äh, Sgt. Blackburn, bist du noch da?
Er fragt nämlich, hi Max, ich habe angefangen, C Sharp zu lernen, weil ich, ähm, weil ich eine Ausbildung als Anwendungsentwickler machen will und die meisten Firmen schon wollen, dass man was kann.
Äh, da wäre ich generell immer ein bisschen vorsichtig, so je nachdem, was das für ein Laden ist.
Natürlich ist es schön, wenn der Azubi schon im Vorfeld was kann, was man aber nicht vergessen darf, ich sage zum Rest gleich was, was man nicht vergessen darf, und ich sage nicht, dass du es vergessen hast, aber was, was manche Firmen, glaube ich, ab und zu vergessen ist.
Ähm, die Ausbildung dient dazu, nicht, dass man es vorher schon kann und einfach eine billige Arbeitskraft ist, sondern die Ausbildung dient dazu, dass man das ordentlich lernt.
Und das wird manchmal einfach vergessen.
Deswegen, ich finde es gar nicht, ich finde es auch bei uns gar nicht so wild, wir haben in letzter Zeit wenig Azubis, das ist, ist so, aber, ähm, ich fände es auch cool, wenn wir wieder mehr hätten, aber vielleicht Ende des Jahres wieder.
Ähm, ja, ich finde es bei uns als Azubis auch ganz cool, wenn die schon was können, aber das ist mir eigentlich egal.
Mir ist es lieber, die interessieren sich generell dafür, als das zu tun.
Was, äh, sie der Ansicht sind, ey, ich, ich habe schon einige gesehen bei uns, so bei uns auch, die gesagt haben, ja, ich mache jetzt die Ausbildung, aber eigentlich kann ich das alles schon und ich mache das ja nur, dass ich eine ordentlich abgeschlossene Ausbildung habe, aber ich kann es ja eh schon.
Und meistens bei denen ist es so, dass sie es nicht richtig können.
Die fragst du dann so ganz einfache Netzwerkgeschichten, zum Beispiel, ja, was passiert denn, wenn Rechner A was zu Rechner B schickt, wie, wie ist dann so der Ablauf?
Dann haben wir keine Ahnung, wie es funktioniert.
Das habe ich mir fast schon gedacht, Patrick.
Das habe ich mir fast schon gedacht.
Mit was hast du dann Smart Home realisiert?
Also als, äh, als Hub und Oberfläche habe ich Home Assistant, nein, ich habe kein KNX.
Ich habe eine Mischung aus, wie gesagt, Home Assistant ist der Hub.
Ich habe eine Mischung aus C-Wave-Netzwerk, ein paar Microcontroller im WLAN, die rumhängen, ein paar WLAN, äh, Steckdosen, ein paar Custom, Custom-Geschichten, wie beispielsweise dem, dem Rollo, Roll, dem Rollern, W, Wickler, das, der halt die Rollos runter macht, ähm, ein bisschen altertümliche Funkgeschichten für die anderen Rollläden, ähm, ja, das ist so eine Mischung aus allem.
Und das Schöne daran ist auch einfach, dass es mit Home Assistant sich gut integrieren lässt.
So.
Ähm, äh, Baumi schreibt die Frage nochmal mit AdWoblos, dass ich sie nicht vergesse, weil, sonst übersehe ich es.
Ach so, genau, ähm, aber ich komme nicht so richtig voran, weil ich nicht weiß, wo ich anfangen soll, beziehungsweise bräuchte ich zu jedem Thema Aufgaben, damit ich es festigen kann.
Ich bin nicht so kreativ, das geht jedem so.
Ähm, beziehungsweise weiß ich nicht, was ich alles machen kann, sodass ich mir selbst Aufgaben stellen könnte.
Hm.
Mit was, mit was lernst du denn, C-Sharp?
Hast du ein Buch?
Oder mit was lernst du das?
Was wurde aus dem Azubi, den ich mal erkannt habe, der gut durchgekommen ist?
Ne, also ja, der hat es geschafft, aber einen guten Abschluss hat er nicht gerade gemacht.
Mich hat aber letztens doch, mich hat letztens mal wieder einer erkannt, letztes Jahr.
Einer der neuen Anwendungsentwickler bei uns.
Der hat so gesagt, äh.
Bist du da, Max?
Ja, wieso?
Ja, wie kommt deine Stimme bekannt vor?
Haha, hab ich gesagt, ach so, wirklich, ja.
Also der wusste Bescheid.
Also ich, exposed.
Mit Videos.
Äh, ja, doch, Videos sind, Videos sind eine gute Quelle, um, um, äh, Sachen zu lernen.
Was ich dir empfehlen würde, Sergeant Blackburn, ist, lese dir mal zumindest die ersten paar Kapitel, bis es dann zu advanceren Themen kommt.
Ähm, nimm dir das mal.
Ich glaube, das ist das Letzte.
Nimm dir das mal.
Nimm dir mal, das ist zwar, das ist zwar von 2012, allerdings die Basics haben sich nicht geändert, ist kostenlos.
Und lese dir das mal durch, bis Artikel, äh, bis, bis, ähm, bis inklusive 16.
Bis 16.
Lese dir das mal bis 16 durch.
Dann weißt du schon ganz gut Bescheid.
Und ich finde, es ist einfacher, das in der Buchform zu lernen, als, ähm, als so.
Ja, und auf die Frage hin, was du machen kannst, als, als, als Aufgaben.
Ich kann dir eigentlich nur empfehlen, neben diesen Standarddingern, die jeder macht, so irgendwie mal, wir fangen, wir machen mal einen Body Mass Index Rechner und sowas.
Das sind so 10 Zeilen, das, das juckt eigentlich gar nicht.
Äh, ich kann dir eigentlich nur empfehlen, überleg dir mal irgendein Thema, was dich interessiert.
Zum Beispiel, falls du einen Battlefield-Server hast, dass du eine Statistikseite für deinen Battlefield-Server machst.
Mit C-Sharp im Backend.
Oder, dass du irgendwas, irgendwas, was dich interessiert.
So diese 0815 Übungsaufgaben.
Und die Übungsaufgaben sind meistens ziemlich kacke.
Und haben mit der Realität auch nicht viel zu tun.
Weil, wenn du, wenn du halbwegs ordentliche Basics drauf hast.
Also sprich, wenn du das Buch gelesen hast, bis Artikel, äh, bis, bis, ähm, Kapitel 16 oder 15 oder was das war.
Dann hast du die Basics drauf.
Wenn man die Basics halbwegs ordentlich drauf hat, dann muss man es ein bisschen benutzen.
Dass man es lernt.
Und während man es benutzt, stellt man dann auch fest, wie die Sachen miteinander funktionieren und zusammenhängen.
Und vor allem das, was man noch nicht gecheckt hat.
Also, das würde ich dir empfehlen.
So, ich hoffe, das hat die Frage beantwortet.
Ähm.
Irgendwas übersehen.
Irgendjemand hat gefragt, ob ich ordentliche Access-Points habe.
Ich hoffe, das hat er mit AdWoblos gestellt.
Genau.
Also, das haben wir beantwortet.
Ich hoffe, hat gepasst.
Hat ja was gebracht.
Ähm.
Wo würdest du die Firewall hinpacken?
Oder nimmst du einfach den Paketfilter vom Mikrotik-Router?
Ja.
Äh.
Brauche ich da heimlich.
Die Packet-Inspection brauchen wir da heimlich.
ALG weiß ich also nicht mal aus dem Kopf, wofür es steht.
Was steht in der ALG?
Application.
Ah, okay.
Ähm.
Application Layer Gateway.
Also quasi, ähm.
Layer 7.
Äh.
Filter.
Das kann der, das, also.
Ein bisschen Layer 4 Plus.
Kann der Mikrotik auch.
Also, der Mikrotik kann zum Beispiel, äh, ein bisschen HTTP verstehen und sowas.
Allerdings ist das nicht so wahnsinnig schnell und schön.
Und die Packet-Inspection brauche ich nicht.
Daheim brauche ich das nicht.
Ich würde, ich würde erst mal am Anfang den Paketfilter und die Firewall vom Mikrotik-Router verwenden.
Okay, ähm.
Besitzt der Bahn immer am Fenster?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Äh.
Welchen Access Point bist du?
Okay, da kommen wir jetzt zum Thema Access Points.
Ähm, hat nämlich hier oben auch schon der Max Electronics gefragt.
Kannst du auch eventuell einen WLAN-Access Point empfehlen?
Am besten einen, der sich gut verlängern lässt.
Eventuell auch eine Version für draußen hat.
Ähm.
Da gibt's eigentlich zwei Sachen.
Für Outdoor.
Äh.
Irgendwie hat mein, mein Headset gerade rumgespackt.
Ähm.
Du könntest entweder die, die Schiene gehen, du könntest dir die MikroTik-Sachen mal angucken.
Allerdings finde ich, sind die MikroTik-Sachen ein bisschen nicht so zeitgemäß.
Die haben ganz viele WLAN-Geschichten, also vor allem die günstigen WLAN-Geschichten bei MikroTik, können bloß 2,4 Gigahertz.
Das ist also quasi noch das alte.
Sie haben zwar mittlerweile auch schon vermehrt Sachen mit 5 Gigahertz, allerdings, so die Einsteiger-Sachen sind alle noch 2,4 Gigahertz.
Also quasi Mikrowelle.
Also, nein, der gleichen Frequenz wie eure Mikrowelle, äh, sind keine Mikrowelle, ähm, und das ist ein bisschen, ein bisschen altertümlich, finde ich, ja.
Ansonsten bin ich eigentlich ein Fan von MikroTik-Sachen, allerdings im WLAN-Bereich hält sich's in Grenzen.
Ähm.
Wo man eigentlich nichts falsch machen kann, sind die Ubiquiti-Dinger.
Also mein Netzwerk-Equipment setzt sich eigentlich so geteilt aus.
Ähm.
Äh, Ubiquiti und MikroTik zusammen.
Ich wollte ja noch, ich hab's in einem der letzten Lives, ich hab's ja erzählt, dass ich eigentlich die Ubiquiti-Dinger wieder weghaben will.
Weil's mir auf den Keks geht, dass die kein ordentliches Webinterface haben, dass man da diesen komischen Unify-Controller für haben will.
Allerdings find ich sie jetzt im Nachhinein betrachtet doch, ähm, fürs WLAN besser.
Also rein vom WLAN her, äh, wie die MikroTik-Dinger.
So, und wenn du dir zum Beispiel, die haben jetzt auch einen neuen, da kann ich allerdings nicht viel dazu sagen.
Ich hab so einen, ich hab so einen, aber die haben jetzt auch einen neuen, da musst du mal gucken.
Ähm, du musst mal gucken, die haben jetzt, die haben jetzt einen neuen, die haben jetzt einen neuen WLAN.
Und Ubiquiti hat ziemlich sicher auch Outdoor-WLANs.
Ähm, der ist auf jeden Fall gut, mit dem kannst du auf jeden Fall nichts falsch machen.
Das ist eines der besten Access-Points, die du dir holen kannst.
Ähm.
Du brauchst allerdings, um die Sachen zu managen, den Unify-Server, kannst du aber auf einem Raspberry laufen lassen.
Oder auf irgendeinem x-beliebigen anderen Rechner, den du so hast.
Oder du kannst im ganz, wenn du es ganz hardcore machen willst, kannst du auch von deinem Smartphone die Dinger, äh, bedienen.
Geht auch.
Nur ein ordentliches Webinterface zum Managen haben sie leider nicht.
Das ist das, was mich da ein bisschen nervt.
Ähm, aber das ist gut.
Also die sind richtig gut.
Und ich geh mal davon aus, die haben auch Outdoor-Varianten davon.
Aber mit dem hier kannst du definitiv nichts falsch machen.
Das ist eines der besten Access-Points, ähm, für den privaten Bereich, der auch erschwinglich ist, den man sich holen kann.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Du brauchst keinen alten Dell-Server hinstellen.
Das ist total Overkill dafür.
Dann hol dir lieber einen Raspberry Pi Zero.
Reicht auch dicke aus.
Ähm, ja, Nico, das ist die nächste Variante.
Du könntest auch dir selbst OpenWrt drauf installieren auf irgendeinem Access-Point, wenn du mehr Optionen brauchst.
Aber.
Aber, damit kannst du wenig falsch machen.
Du musst nur mal gucken, was die, ich hab letztens gelesen, die haben was Neues.
Was ähnlich gut ist, ein bisschen günstiger und, und irgendwie ein paar neuere Features hat.
Keine Ahnung, hab ich mich nicht mit beschäftigt.
Aber da macht man eigentlich nichts mit verkehrt.
Okay, ähm, ja, genau, ich hab auch diesen Access-Point.
Das haben wir, haben wir, hast du deine Klimaanlage geflasht?
Klar.
Chrome, Chromium haben wir auch beantwortet.
VPN-Anbieter.
Wann guckst du eigentlich mal C-Sharp zum Gruseln im Stream?
Wollte ich das?
Könnten wir echt mal machen.
Merke ich mir mal.
Schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Stream-To-Do.
C-Sharp zum Gruseln.
Ich wollte auch meine Vita-Flaschen im Stream, ah.
Da weiß ich aber nicht, ob das Monkatos ist, wenn ich, wenn ich die Vita-Flasche im Stream.
Ubuntu-Server bringt Nextcloud als Snap mit.
Spricht was dagegen, die Nextcloud-Instant als Snap laufen zu lassen?
Oder sollte ich eine konventionelle Installation machen?
Spricht, also ich wüsste nicht, was dagegen spricht, das als Snap laufen zu lassen.
Es spricht, finde ich, generell bei Nextcloud ein bisschen was dagegen.
Ich weiß allerdings nicht, wie das mit dem Snap ist, sie in einem Container laufen zu lassen.
Beziehungsweise in einem Container, der quasi nicht auf eigenes Betriebssystem macht, so wie LXD oder LXC.
Die haben beispielsweise bei ihrem Docker-Image, hatten die jahrelang Probleme bei Nextcloud.
Das hat nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das mit dem Snap ist.
Und ich weiß auch nicht, wie das mit dem aktuellen offiziellen Docker-Container ist.
Ich habe meine Nextcloud in der Regel als LXD-Container laufen.
Das ist quasi, ähm, bis auf den Kernel ein eigenes Betriebssystem, was, äh, Filesystem angeht.
Da kann, kann man nicht viel schief, nicht viel falsch machen eigentlich dann.
Aber ansonsten, wenn das funktioniert, spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen, das als Snap laufen zu lassen.
So, das war die Frage vom Baumi.
Ach, jetzt sehe ich es erst.
Ja, der Patrick hat das gefragt.
Also, ich bin auch Schüler und habe mir das Programmieren selber beigebracht.
Nice.
Sehr, sehr.
Moment.
Ähm, waschbar, das ist doch praktisch, ey.
Ähm, ich hoffe aber, es war wenigstens.
Ähm, aber bislang nur Software.
Ich kann hier Websites, Frontends, Backends bauen, aber habe nicht.
So.
Ich habe nicht so viel Ahnung von Microcontroller oder generell Netzwerk.
Ja gut, äh, Microcontroller ist auch ein Thema.
Da bin ich jetzt auch nicht gerade so da, der, der, der Ultra Pro drin, ne, ne.
Nur weil man ein bisschen ESP32 und Arduino programmieren kann, ist man also nicht so der Microcontroller-Owner.
Ähm, ich würde es, ich würde es halt machen, wenn ich ein Projekt hätte im Endeffekt.
Was das braucht.
Und deswegen finde ich deine Streams so geil.
Das ist auch sehr nice, so.
Weil du dich halt nicht so.
Anscheinend verdammt gut auskennst.
Ah ja.
Ich hab, ich hab einfach schon ein bisschen Erfahrung.
Umso besser man sich auskennt, umso mehr stellt man eigentlich fest, von wie vielen Sachen man eigentlich überhaupt keine Ahnung hat.
RIP deine Frage.
Habe ich die gelöscht einfach so?
Oder hast du sie nicht mit Entwupplos gestellt?
Ne, VPN habe ich doch beantwortet.
Dass ich keinen VPN-Anbieter verwende, dass ich mein eigener VPN-Anbieter bin.
Für daheim.
Ich, ich verwende keinen VPN-Anbieter, um irgendwie Netflix auszudrücken, äh, äh, auszutricksen oder sonst was.
Ne, Hexas, nix verpasst.
Ähm, ich, ich verwende keinen VPN-Anbieter.
Das einzige VPN, was ich verwende, und das habe ich auch gerade aktuell nicht an, ist, wenn ich von außen auf meinen Heim, also bei mir daheim zugreifen will.
Ich würde gerne versuchen, ein Programm zu schreiben, das per SSH auf einen Router-Switch geht und bestimmte Parameter rausschreibt.
Was für eine Sprache würdest du empfehlen?
Gar keine, ich würde mir mal SNMP angucken.
Wenn es unbedingt sein muss, per SSH, dann würde ich es über einen Shell-Skript machen.
Das ist total easy, im Shell-Skript, sich einloggen und Kommandos ausführen, SSH.
Und wenn es unbedingt eine Sprache sein soll, ist die Frage, was, auf welchem Betriebssystem du es laufen lassen willst, ja.
Wenn du es auf Linux laufen lassen willst, dann eindeutig ein Shell-Skript.
Da brauchst du nicht viel SSH, User-Add-Dings, Anführungszeichen.
Wenn du es aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht in einem Shell-Skript machen willst, und es unter Linux ist, dann kannst du es mit allem möglichen machen, Ruby, Python, sonst was.
Ich würde da irgendwie schnell ein Skript zusammenwursten.
So, und wenn du es wirklich in einer etwas advanceren Geschichte machen willst, dann kannst du es auch mit C-Sharp in .NET Core machen und eine SSH-Library verwenden.
Du kannst es auch in Go.
Du kannst es auch in .NET Core machen, sei ich vollkommen egal.
Wobei, prinzipiell würde ich mir erstmal angucken, SNMP.
Weil SNMP ist genau für sowas da.
Das wurde dafür quasi erfunden, um Sachen von Netzwerkgeräten abfragen zu können.
Kannst du es auch in Assembly machen?
Ja, also ich würde sagen, der Glocks HD programmiert uns bis zum nächsten Stream in SSH-Agent in Assembler.
Allerdings, bitteschön, in Assembler.
In diesem ESP32-ULP-Assembler, der nur 8 Befehle hat.
Eats, wusste ich, wusste ich, dass es für dich kein Problem ist.
Easy.
Ähm, ja, Martin, beantwortet.
Ähm, gibt es auch eine Firewall gegen Layer 8, der Computer ausschalten?
Oder die Kneifzange?
Kneifzange ist da eigentlich immer am besten dafür geeignet.
Ja, der Hawks hat recht.
Man muss...
Wenn man die Basics ein bisschen gecheckt hat, wenn man ein Buch gelesen hat,
muss man sich einfach ein paar Sachen überlegen, die man machen will.
Er schreibt ja auch hier,
er wird es versuchen, mir mit der Seite und danach selbst Sachen zu programmieren, die mir Spaß machen.
Ja.
Am besten ist natürlich, wenn du noch irgendwas findest, was dich nicht nur interessiert,
sondern was dann auch, wenn es fertig ist, irgendwas bringt.
Ja, bei mir ist es aktuell viel im Zusammenhang mit meiner Heimautomatisierung, wo ich machen muss.
Zum Beispiel habe ich mir was gebastelt, was bei...
Das ist übrigens auch was Schönes.
Was bei, ähm, DPD, DHL, UPS und Amazon Logistics abfragt, ob gerade Pakete bei mir auf dem Weg sind.
Für C-Sharp gibt es auch eine schöne Twitch-Library.
Echt? Welche denn?
Das war gar nicht so einfach.
Da wird ein bisschen rumgetrickst, ne?
Ich, ich hab, ich nehm so eine allgemeine Tracking-Seite und wenn das irgendwie gerade rumbackt,
versuche ich direkt abzurufen von Amazon und so.
Also, das ist auch sowas.
Das bringt dann auch was, wenn's, äh, wenn's fertig ist.
Nach sowas würde ich gucken.
Oder einfach Sachen, die einen halt interessieren.
Ist immer schwierig, dann jetzt konkrete Beispiele zu sagen.
Irgendwas, was zu dem passt, was du sonst machst.
Ansonsten, wenn dir gar nichts einfällt, kannst du ja im nächsten Stream nochmal, nochmal, nochmal, äh, was...
Kannst du ja nochmal schreiben im nächsten Stream, dass dir nichts eingefallen ist, dann denken wir uns irgendwas aus.
Allesamt, allesamt, ja.
So, ähm.
Aktuelle Serie auf YouTube und Twitch, in der ein 8-Bit-PC von Grund aufgebaut wird.
Ja, wenn man sich dafür interessiert, klar.
Hast dein oder das nächste verpasst.
Kann der ESP2866 irgendeine Verschlüsselung, oder ist das so klein, so langsam?
Doch, du kannst.
Also, der ESP2866 kann natürlich alle möglichen Verschlüsselungen aus Libraries fürgibt, oder die du selbst machst.
Also, potenziell alle.
Aber halt nicht so wahnsinnig schnell.
Ähm, was kein Problem ist, ist SSL zum Beispiel.
Das ist nämlich schon eingebaut.
Dann nimmst du anstatt dem Wi-Fi-Client einfach den Wi-Fi-Client Secure und schon kannst du ohne Probleme, äh, SSL, HTTPS, TLS, ähm, Verbindungen aufbauen.
Das funktioniert, ist kein Problem.
Das schnellste ist es in der Tat nicht.
Allerdings in der Standard-Library ist, glaube ich, zumindest bei Arduino,
ist sogar schon, ähm, so die üblichen Verdächtigen AES, RSA und SHA-256 mit drinne.
Nicht, nicht ultra schnell, aber für die kleinen Datenmengen, die so ein ESP3266 überträgt, kein Ding.
Selbst gemacht habe ich es noch nicht, ähm, außer SSL-Verbindung.
Ja, damit habe ich es schon gemacht.
Allerdings habe ich es schon mit dem ESP32 gemacht und im Prinzip wird es wahrscheinlich nicht so ein großer Unterschied sein dazwischen.
Ein Unterschied ist dazwischen, ähm, doch, es gibt einen großen Unterschied dazwischen zwischen ESP32 und ESP2866.
Nämlich, dass der ESP32 Hardware-AES drauf hat.
Und ich glaube der ESP2866 nicht.
So.
Ist beantwortet.
Würdest du OpenVPN und Router trennen, also vom Gerät hören?
Nö.
Würde ich nicht machen.
Kann man machen.
Würde ich aber so pauschal nicht machen.
Liegt zum größten...
Es ist ja immer so eine Sache, die man abwägen muss, ja.
Generell ist dieses ganze Security-Thema immer eine permanente Abwägung zwischen, wie einfach soll es im Handling sein und wie sicher soll es sein.
In der Regel sind, umso sicherer die Sachen sind, umso komplizierter sind sie zu handeln.
Sowohl für den User als auch für den Admin.
Oder auch für den Programmierer.
Für alle.
Ähm, in dem Fall traue ich MikroTik eigentlich zu, dass sie in der Lage sind, so ein Standard-Ding wie OpenVPN in ordentlicher Qualität anzuführen.
Und ich mir keinen eigenen Raspberry oder irgendwas hinstellen muss als OpenVPN-Gateway.
Würde ich nicht machen. Ich würde das OpenVPN auf dem MikroTik-.. oder auf dem...
auf dem Router betreiben.
Oh Fuck.
Hab grad..
Hab grad ein bisschen Johannisbeeren gefuttert..
Hab grad nen Stiel mitgefundert.
... danncuts
Ah.
Wonka-Grün, ey.
Wonka-Smoke
ok grün zeug von bush im garten schmeckt nicht gut
auch ein vpn auf mikrotik hast du habe ich nicht warum ist sie so schlecht weshalb ist
sie so schlecht nur zu lieber discord oder aktuell discord discord beste echt ist das
so okay ich habe noch keine vpn über mikrotik gemacht ich hätte nicht gedacht dass du so
scheiße ist gibt es gibt es dings hier ist das war ja war ja gar das neue oder neue neue schritt
gibt es das von mikrotik eigentlich tomtastic ich kann dazu überhaupt nichts sagen ich habe
es noch nicht ausprobiert ich wollte schon mal eine ganze weile ausprobieren okay gibt es
anscheinend noch nicht also sollte ob vpn wirklich so scheiße auf mikrotik sein kann
man sich sehr überlegen ob man ein geld hinstellt wobei ich jetzt
eigentlich davon ausgegangen wäre dass das ganz okay ist ich schreibe ich schreibe mir das mal
bei meinem stream ideen to do's auf so war ja grad ausprobieren können vielleicht auch in raspberry
oder so ok ja da habe ich jetzt was zu gesagt also wie gesagt sollte das wirklich so kacke
sein dass wir auch ein vpn auf mikrotik router dann muss man sich dort wirklich was anderes um
legen aber ich kann es weder bestätigen noch widerlegen irgendwie okay das ist
natürlich ein ziemlicher mist welches linux empfiehlst du für daily
kommt drauf an was du für einen für eine was du für linux kenntnisse hast also
wenn du dich schon ganz gut auskennt oder zumindest die basics kennst ich
bin ja verfechter von von mancharo mit i3 oder generell mancharo beste mancharo
beste waller ich habe irgendwie den fall das falsche profil eingestellt na und
sagen warum sieht meine konsole so kacke aus ja das hier ist auch mancharo mit i3
das verwende ich auch auf der
arbeit ist für mich die beste distribution für desktop systeme wenn
man sich ein bisschen auskennt gefällt mir persönlich einfach am besten
i3 ist ein bisschen rise of milchreis das ist ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig
i3 hat halt keine fenster also man kann man kann natürlich auch fenster machen
wenn man fenster will aber normalerweise will man keine fenster für windows
benutzer
beziehungsweise für gnome kde xfc lx de was es da nicht alles gibt benutzer ist i3 ein
bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig weil er hat gewöhnt sind fenster zu verwenden allerdings bin ich der
meinung in der regel will man so was wie fenster gar nicht haben bei i3 ist die philosophie halt
alles fullscreen das heißt wenn ich mache das jetzt hier mal zu das heißt wenn ich nicht aufzapfen
Und wenn ich nichts offen habe, ist der jeweilige Desktop einfach leer.
Außer in dem Hintergrundbild.
Es gibt ja auch keine Desktop-Icons oder sonst was, was ja ganz logisch ist, weil ich meine, es gibt kein Fenster, was man davor machen kann.
Ich glaube, man kann mit ein bisschen Trick 17 einen Desktop mit Icons machen, aber das ist komplett sinnlos, weil du hast eh immer ein Fenster davor.
So, wenn man dann was startet, das erste, was passiert, sobald man es startet, geht Fullscreen der Browser auf.
So, sobald du eine Anwendung startest, in dem Fall der Browser, geht die immer Fullscreen auf.
Startet man eine zweite Anwendung, teilen sie sich den Bildschirm.
Startet man eine dritte Anwendung, teilen sie sich den Bildschirm.
Man kann natürlich dann auch einstellen, wie das funktioniert.
Wie das platziert sein soll.
Also man kann sagen, hier unten hätte man gerne sowas, hier oben hätte man gerne sowas.
Und da hätten wir einen Browser.
Natürlich kann man die auch noch unterschiedlich irgendwie verschieben, wie man es gerne hätte.
Aber das ist die Philosophie von E3.
Man kann Fenster machen, aber normalerweise macht man eigentlich keine Fenster.
Man kann das Ganze auch stacken, dass man hier oben so Tabs hat, innerhalb von einem Desktop.
Aber man ist eigentlich null.
Man ist eigentlich null mit Fenstermanagement beschäftigt.
Und das ist das, was ich daran gut finde, weil man hat keine Fenster.
Wie kann man bei E3 Scaling machen, wenn man eine High DPI hat?
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine High DPI.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn es GTK ist, kann man irgendeinen Scale-Faktor angeben.
Wobei man halt sagen muss, High DPI und ordentliches Scaling ist unter Linux eh noch nicht so.
Das wäre, was die hier dazu schreiben, das ist von 2016.
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung.
Aber es gibt einen Archie-Eintrag für High DPI.
Irgendwelche X-Server-Hacks.
Ich glaube, da muss man einfach ein bisschen rumprobieren.
Es ist unter Linux eh noch nicht so toll mit High DPI und 4K-Displays.
So, haben wir beantwortet.
Schnell Command zu überwachen.
Ja, das war irgendwas zu was anderem vorhin.
Was hältst du generell vom Studium bei dem Software-Entwicklungssegment?
Hä?
Ich weiß nur, dass man viel Java lernt in der Uni.
Oder generell.
Im Studium lernt man relativ viel Java.
Wahrscheinlich, weil da alle Java können und denken, Java, beste Alter.
Beste, ja.
Aber ich bin, ihr kennt mich ja, ich bin nicht der Ansicht, dass Java beste ist.
Ich mag Java nicht.
Ich habe gegen die Java vor M nix, aber ich mag Java nicht.
Wie switchst du zwischen Windows und Linux mit...
Ähm...
Steuerung, Windows-Taste, Pfeil nach rechts und Steuerung, Windows-Taste, Pfeil nach links.
Pfeil rechts, Pfeil links, Pfeil rechts, Pfeil links.
Ja.
Mehr durchdrehen, please.
PPGA-Board.
Das PPGA-Board hat sich jetzt schon ausgezahlt.
So viele Fragen, wie man heute durchkriegt.
Wo ich nix vergesse, haben wir selten gehabt.
Hatten wir.
Welchen Router benutzt du privat?
Also ich habe einmal natürlich von Unity Media das Ding, was dabei war.
Ich habe die billigste Fritzbox überhaupt bei der Telekom vorne dran.
Und dahinter habe ich einen MikroTik-Hex-PoE.
Dann habe ich vorne an der Klingel noch einen Mini-MikroTik-Access-Point.
Einfach einen, der über PoE läuft.
Und an Switchen habe ich einen Ubiquiti ES16XG.
Das ist ein 10G-Switch mit 12 FSP-Plus-Ports und 4 10G-Kupfer-Ports.
Dann habe ich noch einen MikroTik-4-Port-10G-Switch und ein Billig-TP-Link-Ding.
So, das dürfte jetzt alles gewesen sein.
Ach ja, und Access-Points ist Ubiquiti Access-Points.
Hatten wir schon.
Hatten wir auch schon.
Welche...
Alter, ich hätte das Johannisbeutel nicht essen sollen.
Welche Skript-Sprache würdest du für einen Anfänger mit Linux empfehlen?
Bash.
Bash ist das universellste, was du immer gebrauchen kannst.
Im Vergleich zu Python und Ruby hast du halt das Schöne, wenn du ein bisschen Bash kannst,
wirst du generell im Bedienen von der Kommando-Zeile auch besser.
Das Erste, was ich lernen würde, wenn ich irgendwas skripten will unter Linux, ist Bash.
Bash ist nicht die schönste Sprache.
Bash ist auch sicherlich nicht die schnellste Sprache und auch nicht die konsistenteste Sprache.
Allerdings ist Bash zum Einstieg und generell für Linux-Handling an sich das Beste, was man lernen kann.
Bash.
Ja.
Danach hätte ich früher gesagt Ruby und ich mache immer noch viel mit Ruby.
Allerdings hat Python generell Ruby so ein bisschen den Rang abgelaufen.
Nicht nur im Wissen.
Aber auch im wissenschaftlichen Umfeld allgemein.
Neues Ruby-Zeug gibt es heute kaum noch.
Python ist aber, glaube ich, wenn man auf GitHub guckt oder generell bei Umfragen,
die Sprache mit dem meisten Hype, den meisten neuen Projekten, den meisten neuen geschriebenen Zeilen.
Also Python ist ganz, ganz vorne aktuell.
Ruby ist auf dem absteigenden Ast.
Leider. Wobei ich Ruby war.
Würdest du einen höheren Abschluss als mittlere Reife für die Ausbildung...
Das ist vollkommen...
Egal.
Es ist vollkommen egal.
Also es ist nur dann nicht egal, wenn derjenige, der Leute sucht, denkt, dass es wichtig ist.
Für die Ausbildung an sich ist es faktisch.
Es ist für mich, da steht das fest, ist es egal, was du für einen Abschluss hast.
Solange du genommen wirst.
Ja, geht's dir ja gerade drum.
Aber für die Ausbildung bringt es dir nichts.
Ich habe, ich habe auch noch mittlere Reife gemacht.
Ist allerdings schon ein bisschen näher.
Ich habe auch ursprünglich nur mittlere Reife gemacht.
Und wenn du was kriegst, was geht, ja.
Vor allem in Regionen, wo halt viel Technik ist.
Zum Beispiel Frankfurt.
Köln wahrscheinlich auch.
Aber Frankfurt insbesondere, da ist ja, wo du hinspuckst, irgendein Rechenzentrum in irgendeiner Ecke.
Da findest du auf jeden Fall was.
Und in der Ausbildung selbst profitierst du nicht wirklich von.
Die Ausbildung, also die Fachinformatik...
Die richtige Ausbildung ist scheißeinfach.
Sagen wir es genau.
Wir sagen es mal, wie es ist.
Die ist wirklich einfach.
Das schafft jeder.
Die IHK-Abschlussprüfung und auch die Berufsschule.
Das ist wirklich einfach.
Berufsschule ist absolut easy as fuck.
Und die IHK-Abschlussprüfung hat mit dem, was man im beruflichen Umfeld macht, eh nichts zu tun.
Da geht es ja darum, dass man die Überprüfung vorher durchgelesen hat.
Das war's.
Also die Ausbildung ist echt nicht schwer.
Einzige Fenster des Windows Explorer, okay.
Hatten wir.
Ja.
Ist das Dualboot?
Das ist ne VM.
Kommt ganz auf die Uni an.
Jaja, klar.
Dacht ich mir auch.
Wirst du eventuell vom Hex auf die 19 Zoll Variante wechseln?
Ach, soll da was Neues kommen?
Äh, der, der Hex hat nen Switch drin.
Allerdings hat der Hex bloß, ähm, bloß 5 Ports.
Das ist halt jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Was für eine VM nutzt du?
Das ist eine VM bei Workstation.
Cheat, was meinst du denn, auf welche Variante, ob ich auf was für ne Variante wechseln will?
Also ich hatte jetzt eigentlich nicht vor, was zu wechseln.
Das einzige, was ich abschaffen wollte, ist mein Ubiquiti 10G Switch.
Den brauch ich nicht.
Der ist komplett overkill.
Äh, ja, Cheat, das hab ich mir überlegt, ob ich mir nicht, ob ich mir nicht noch nen MikroTik Switch kaufe.
Einen ganz einfachen MikroTik Gigabit Switch mit irgendwie...
Ahnung, 20 Ports, 24 Ports oder so, ja.
Das hatte ich mir überlegt.
Die Sache ist die, dass die meisten günstigen, ähm, Switche von, von MikroTik
oder die, die heißen ja die CRS-Dinger von denen, die, die, die, die Router-Switche, die sie da haben,
dass die nicht die besten Router zum Routen-Routen sind.
Die haben meistens ne schlechtere CPU drin als der Hex.
Das sind eigentlich eher Switche, die nen, die, die nen Router-OS drauf haben, was theoretisch Layer 3 und 4 ein bisschen kann,
aber, ähm, das ist nicht sonderlich, sonderlich gut.
Die haben zum Beispiel auch keine Hardware-Encryption-Dinger drauf,
was heißt, dass man schon mal VPN ziemlich vergessen kann, wenn man ein bisschen Bandbreite drüber haben will.
Also wahrscheinlich nicht.
Welche Geräte ich an PoE hab?
Äh, nur diesen Mini-MikroTik-Access-Point, der vorne bei mir in der Klingel eingebaut ist.
Der ist 48 Volt, ähm, PoE.
Ja, das liegt einfach daran,
weil ich nicht so viele Adern hatte, die durch die DIN-Wand noch frei waren.
Bei euch wird sehr viel C++ Java gemacht.
An der Uni, ist doch nice.
Generell würde ich sagen, es ist eigentlich gar nicht mal so wichtig, mit welcher Programmiersprache man anfängt.
Ich persönlich mag Java nicht.
Ich finde auch, dass, ähm, C bzw. C++ und C++ noch weniger,
dass C++ wirklich keine gute Sprache ist zum Einsteigen.
Das Problem an C++ ist, dass C++ einfach 30 Jahre lang, äh, oder 30 Jahre, äh, wildeste Syntax mit sich rumschleppt.
Und ganz viel davon sagen ja die C++-Leute heute, soll man gar nicht mehr verwenden.
Es geht noch, ähm, es ist teilweise wichtig, dass es da ist, weil es quasi in C so gemacht wird.
Ähm, um, also ich finde C++ ist an sich keine schöne Sprache.
Ich meine, C++, ich, ich kenne kaum eine Sprache, ey, noch nicht mal Erlang oder sowas,
besteht aus so vielen komischen, verschiedenen Klammern.
Und Erlang ist nur Klammern.
Dafür runde Klammern.
C++ ist wir.
Was, was die Syntax angeht.
Und was man machen soll und was nicht.
Und, und, dürfen tut man ja theoretisch alles unter C++, aber manches soll man nicht machen.
Und ich, ich finde es zum Einstieg keine schöne Sprache.
Äh, X-Final.
Äh, X-Fanatics sagt, wenn man doch, jedoch mit C++ anfängt, fallen alle anderen leichter und man hat ein besseres Verständnis davon, was so vor sich geht.
Das sehe ich anders.
Ich denke, die meisten Leute, die mit C++ anfangen, werden davon komplett versaut.
Entweder sorgt es dafür, dass sie nie wieder Bock haben zu programmieren, was verständlich wäre.
Ähm, oder dass sie eigentlich gar keine Ahnung haben, wie man das ordentlich macht.
C++ neigt dazu, dass man so lang rumbastelt.
Bis es geht.
Und wenn es nicht geht, wird es einfach zu, zu, äh, genau, zu Voidpointer gecastet.
Dann geht's.
Also ich finde nicht, dass man mit C++ Vorteile hat, wenn man damit anfängt.
Du wirst als Einsteiger C++ nie auf ein gutes Level kriegen, weil dir einfach viel zu viel Kenntnisse drum herum fehlen.
Warum man manche Sachen so machen sollte oder manche Sachen halt eben so nicht.
Allein schon, wenn man sich überlegt.
In C castest du einfach.
In C schreibst du einfach einen Pointer hin.
Nicht so in C++.
In C++ hast du StaticCast, Autocast, ReinterpretCast, ConstCast, äh, nee, Autocast hast du nicht, Schwachsinn.
Äh, was auch immer.
Ähm, dann den normalen C-Cast hast du noch.
Ähm, dann hast du den RAW, dann deine RAW-Pointer.
Dann hast du den, den Adress-Operator.
Den gibt's ja auch noch.
Wo manchmal halt ganz klar ist, wann, wie, wo was verändert wird.
Ähm, dann hast du, ähm, Autopointer, Unic-Pointer, äh, äh, Shared-Pointer.
Das ist, ich sag gegen die Konzepte nix.
Die sind an sich nicht verkehrt, aber es ist einfach ein bisschen, das zu erfassen, ist einfach ein bisschen, ne ziemlich hohe Hürde, ja.
Dann gibt's so Sachen wie Autopointer, was man nicht mal verwenden soll.
Naja.
Gibt auch noch Const.
Ey, es gibt in C++ ganz merkwürdige Sachen, ja.
Dann hast du irgendwie diese, diese R-Value-Geschichte.
Weak-Pointer.
Es gibt ja in C++ irgendwie sowas noch.
Const und und.
Ähm, und dann, dann kann man, dann kann man irgendwie da eine Lambda draus machen.
Der Capture da noch irgendwas.
Ähm.
Und.
Ach, und da hast du nicht gesehen, äh.
Und dann kannst du noch sowas hier machen.
Reference auf Blupf.
Das da.
Und dann hier, ey.
Das ist gültige C++-Syntax irgendwie.
Ja, Lambda, gegen, gegen Lambda-Syntax kann man nix sagen.
Wobei doch, gegen die Lambda-Syntax kann man aber sagen, ich find die Lambda-C++-Syntax hässlich.
Also irgendwie, ist merkwürdig.
Ey, mag vielleicht auch daran liegen, dass ich nicht der allergrößte C++-Kenner bin.
Oder auch nicht der allergrößte C++-Fan.
Allerdings, denk ich, zum Einstieg ist C++ nix, nix.
Ich find Lambda's an sich nicht schlecht.
Ich mag das unter anderem.
Schade, hab ich überhaupt keine Probleme mit Lambda.
Unter JavaScript ist es sogar schön, dass es das mittlerweile gibt.
Ja.
Ich mein.
Was hat die denn bei C++ wieder da geritten?
Dass man dafür jetzt irgendwie eckige Klammern nimmt.
Ich hab das Gefühl, manche C++-Syntax-Sachen entstehen so, dass sie da in ihrem Gremium sitzen und sagen, hey.
Welches Zeichen hat dann die wenigsten doppeldeutigen Bedeutungen zurzeit in C++?
Und sagt dann irgendeiner, und.
Oder, oder, eckige Klammer.
Und dann sagen sie, ja, dann lasst den neuen Operator doch mit und und eckiger Klammer machen.
So kommt mir das teilweise vor.
Wenn man mal.
Wow.
Mein Browser ist gerade abgekackt.
Ich seh, ich seh nix mehr auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Also, ich hab grad keine Vorschau mehr auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Äh, jetzt.
Okay, es geht wieder.
Warum auch immer.
Was auch immer das gewesen ist.
Ja, genau.
See out.
Warum man.
See out unbedingt.
Warum man da unbedingt den.
Diesen komischen.
Ich mein.
Ehrlich, ich kenn keine anderen Sprachen.
Wo man diesen Operator überhaupt.
Wobei.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Ich sag das jetzt einfach mal.
Wo man, wo man den Shift Operator überhaupt überschreiben kann.
Kann man das in C Sharp machen?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob man das in C Sharp überschreiben kann.
Okay, man kann das.
Man kann das in C Sharp auch überschreiben.
Na gut.
Aber ich hab noch nie.
Und ich verwende das jetzt schon ein paar Jahre.
Ich hab noch nie den Shift Operator überschrieben.
Noch nie.
Ich wüsste gar nicht wozu.
Okay, wenn du irgendwelchen Low Level Int Mathe Stelz vielleicht machst.
Ja, mit irgendwelchen eigenen Typen.
Aber normalerweise.
Warum muss man den Shift Operator überschreiben?
Mir fällt dazu überhaupt nichts ein.
Warum?
Und vor allem.
Jede andere Geschichte.
Jede ordentliche andere Funktion wird einfach.
Als Funktion mit Klammern aufgerufen.
Aber nicht so See out in C++.
Ich.
Das hat einfach so viele Fallstricke.
Dass ich nicht denke, dass es eine schöne Einstiegssprache ist.
So.
Also war es das.
YouTuber.
Mit 2,000 Subs.
In 2019.
Ohne Gaming WLAN.
Mittlerweile gibt es alles.
Es gibt.
Kennt Ihr noch.
Den Lack Bustering.
Das war doch auch so ein komisches Gerät.
Was angeblich die Online Games verbessern sollte.
Amona.
ob es das überhaupt noch gibt.
Nimmst du das noch?
Leck, basta.
Tatsächlich, gibt es noch.
Oh.
Geh weg.
Geh weg. Skamas Seite war das.
Ich kann jetzt mal nachgucken.
Äh.
Warum ist mein Bildschirm schwarz?
Ist bei euch auch der...
Auch die Vorschau schwarz vom Bildschirm?
Nee, oder?
Ich glaube, das liegt einfach an meinem Browser.
Oh, nö. Okay, passt.
Okay, ich habe neu geladen. Jetzt funktioniert es.
Was ich immer...
Ich habe so einen Tick.
Also neben dem Copy und Paste.
Immer, wenn ich eine Seite aufgemacht habe,
die Skamas ist,
dann mache ich
den Prozessexplorer auf
und gucke
danach, ob irgendwie der China-Virus
läuft im Hintergrund.
Was eigentlich totaler Schwachsinn ist
mit dem Chrome und dem aktivierten...
Achso, Moment. Das hat ja bei euch wieder den Bildschirm jetzt.
So.
Ähm.
Gucke ich immer nach.
Oh, ist der China-Virus am Laufen?
Da stelle ich fest, ein...
Außer die Scripted Sandbox 64
ist am Laufen.
Das ist, glaube ich, irgendein Visual Studio-Ding, hä?
Ähm.
Ob der China-Virus am Laufen ist, stelle ich fest.
Ah, der China-Virus ist nicht am Laufen.
Ähm.
Das Schöne ist, wenn man hier Dings hat,
Uplog Origin, man ist eigentlich relativ safe
auf den meisten Seiten.
Es gibt kein
Lackbuster mehr.
Warum gibt es den Lackbuster nicht mehr zu kaufen?
Das war doch so eine
tolle High-End-Netzwerk-
Optimierungs-Hardware.
Ich meine, guck mal, wie geil
da schon ausgesehen hat der Lackbuster,
Alter, hier.
Und dann dieses High-End-Interface.
Krass, oder?
Mega-Upload.
Leute, muss das jetzt sein
oder muss das nicht sein?
Muss!
Hahaha.
Okay.
Mega-Upload.
Klow.
Wie es einfach das Video
gespiegelt hat.
Ob der wusste,
in welchem Video er da landet?
Wir hatten
alle keinen blassen Schimmer,
was uns überhaupt geht, ey.
...
Das war doch was, hä?
So ein krasser Hit.
Schon lange nicht mehr gehört hier.
Also wer denkt, es kommt noch mehr,
das war es zum größten Teil.
Check it out, check it out,
check it out.
Check it out, ja.
Check it out.
Irgendwie kriegt man da
gute Laune bei.
Irgendwie kriegt man da gute Laune bei.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum.
Aber irgendwie kriegt man da gute Laune bei.
Mega.
Okay, das war es jetzt.
Das geht die ganze Zeit so weiter jetzt.
Das war es jetzt im Endeffekt.
Mehr kommt da nicht.
4.000 Kommentare.
Ja, ist gut jetzt.
Mega Upload.
Oh Mann.
Ah, das war noch was.
Es hat irgendjemand gefragt, ob jemand
Mega NZ verwendet.
Eigentlich nicht.
Also sehr, sehr selten.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob das,
das hat er doch, glaube ich, verkauft an irgendwelche
Chinesen oder so.
Gibt es die Domain eigentlich noch?
Oh.
Kann man die sich registrieren?
Nicht available.
Kann sich Mega Upload nicht registrieren.
Ja, das stimmt.
Sirius Maxx, habe ich ganz vergessen.
Der war in MW3 auf Platz 1.
Ja, da gab es sogar ein YouTube Video von ihm.
Mach mal
Who is Mega Upload?
Ja, kann man machen.
Ah, ist, ist, äh.
Äh, gibt's nix.
Gibt's nix.
Tja.
Okay, haben wir beantwortet.
Ah, Satin Blackburn in Stuttgart auf dem Land.
Schwer machst du finden.
Okay, da kann ich, kann ich jetzt nix zu sagen.
Aber nach Ulm ist es nicht so weit, oder?
In Ulm gibt's auch
relativ viel Technik-Kram.
Ich war mal bei einer Firma, die in Ulm
ihren Sitz hatte.
War es bestimmt bei Elotrix.
Ja, genau.
Ganz, ganz.
Wird's gewesen sein.
Ähm.
Scan Plus.
Äh, die kenn ich.
Ja, die kenn ich.
Das war auch in der Ecke da hinten.
Nicht weit weg gewesen.
Wo ist eigentlich der Master-Krabber?
Der krabbt.
Ähm.
Genau, das haben wir.
Äh, was für eine Fremd benutzt du?
Das ist vor allem der Workstation.
Das hab ich schon beantwortet, ne?
Router-Ball hatten wir auch schon.
D++-System haben wir jetzt eigentlich
lang genug durchgebracht.
Durchgekaut.
Hast du irgendwo einen Guide, den du benutzt hast,
um die Steckdosenleiste zu flashen?
Ja.
Das hier.
Übelst easy.
Das.
Tuya-Convert.
Patrick, bringen die Leute nicht auf falsche Ideen, ne?
Ja.
Ich weiß.
Hast auch schon lange nichts mehr von Leuten gehört,
die sich ins Netzwerkkabel-Legswitch eingebaut haben.
Gibt's bestimmt immer noch.
Also, ich würde wundern, wenn
die Leute damit aufgehört hätten.
Weil mich würde es auch wundern, im gleichen Zuge,
wenn das bei COD nicht mehr möglich wäre.
Das geht da bestimmt immer noch genauso gut.
Hehehe.
Ach, so sieht's aus.
Kennst du auch noch den Technisatz-Song?
Ne.
Was ist der Technisatz-Song?
Freiheit, die vom Himmel kommt.
Ich glaub, das wollen wir uns jetzt nicht geben.
Ach, du.
Geh weg.
Technisatz-Schlager.
Ja, Technisatz.
Haste denn mal vom Playdate gehört?
Ist ne Art Gameboy mit ner Kurbel.
Ich find's ne coole Idee.
Sagt mir überhaupt nix.
Klingt eigentlich eher wie irgendwie Sexspielzeug oder sowas.
Playdate.
Keine Ahnung, was Playdate sein soll.
Ich will's jetzt auch nicht suchen.
Wer weiß, was man da alles findet.
Schon mal Autobattler wie Auto-Chess oder TFT.
TFT.
TFT ist das LoL-Ding, ne?
Äh, nein.
Irgendwie geht der Hype auch voll an mir vorbei.
Ich warte noch drauf, bis Crytek damit rauskommt.
Crytek war immer zu spät.
MOBA, Hype vorbei, Crytek, MOBA.
Battle Royale, Hype vorbei, Crytek, Battle Royale.
Als nächstes kommt Autobattler, Hype vorbei, Crytek, Autobattler.
Was macht Crytek eigentlich so?
Gibt's denn von denen Neues?
Also, Far Cry 75 oder so.
Ne, nicht Far Cry, Crysis.
Acht.
Was machen die so?
Das ist übrigens das, das Crytek Battle Royale.
Was macht Crytek so?
Irgendwie nix Interessantes.
Die machen wahrscheinlich Star Citizen Engine jetzt.
Und.
Das geht mir auch eh nicht rauskommen.
So Leute.
Es ist 20 Uhr 51, ne?
Wir haben, wisst ihr, was wir gemacht haben von den Sachen, die wir machen wollten?
Nichts.
Nichts gemacht von dem, was wir machen wollten.
Oder was ich machen wollte.
Nichts gemacht.
Wir haben nicht in China eingekauft.
Richtig.
Außer eine Sache.
Wir haben auch kein ESP32 Multisplitting programmiert.
Das heißt, eigentlich können wir morgen Abend genau wieder den gleichen Kram machen.
Und ich muss dann nicht mal den Titel ändern.
Das ist doch nice, oder?
Das ist mal calculated.
Das ist massiv, Big Brain.
Quick Muffs.
Was macht eigentlich, was macht eigentlich Big Shark so?
Gibt's von dem irgendwas Neues?
Big Shark returns.
Men don't dance.
Big Shark, da ist er.
Och Gott, das kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
Big Shark hat was Neues seit heute.
Oder?
Es ist uralt.
Warum steht dann da seit einem Tag, was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Debated.
Das ist nur um mich zu debaten.
Okay, gibt nichts Neues von Big Shark.
Gibt's was Neues?
Haftbefehl 2019.
Schrei also mit Haftbefehl.
1. Februar.
April.
Eh, ich ho instance mich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht.
Stream mal morgen nicht tagsüber.
Ich bin morgen tagsüber überhaupt nicht da.
Money Boy.
Heißt Maniboy wieder Money Boy?
Dann hieß das doch zwischenzeitlich irgendwie...
ESL. attempt listen里 usb plug.
Frag mich nicht.
Irgendwie so ähnlich.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Was auch immer...
Call again mc queen
arez
alleine, wenn ich mir solche deutsche
Hip-Hop-Geschichten anschaue, eigentlich einzig und allein
zur Belustigung an. Das ist alles.
Musikalische
Qualität erwarte ich da nicht.
Und kriegt
gefühlt auch keiner hin.
Wenn man sich mal die Texte da teilweise anhört
oder auch die ganze Musik, also
das wirkt auf mich nicht so, als ist
das künstlerisch jetzt so anspruchsvoll, als
könnten das
nur wenige. Das wirkt
meistens ziemlich, ziemlich belanglos
und ziemlich
easy zu machen alles.
Ich glaube, die größten
Aufwand bei dieser 0815
Hip-Hop-Geschichte haben noch die
Typen, die im Studio den Scheiß halbwegs hörbar
zusammenmixen müssen.
Also mir kann keiner erzählen,
dass wenn man sich die Texte da teilweise durchliest,
die die von sich geben, dass das
wahnsinnig viel Brain erfordert, diese
Dinger von sich zu dingsen.
Max Schau, Helene Fischer,
ja, ganz, ganz bestimmt.
Das einzige, was ich mir jetzt anerkenne, ist,
dass fürs Reingehen allein
zur Belustigung.
Ich find's immer geil, wie viele das dann ernst nehmen.
Wobei ich glaube, ja, Money Boy ist mittlerweile
auch so
ursprünglich mal so als Verarschung
gestartet und mittlerweile ist er da wahrscheinlich
voll drauf hängen geblieben.
Ähm, so.
Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Das Pepega-Board,
ach du Scheiße, ist ja schon wieder alles voll.
Haben wir beantwortet? Haben wir beantwortet?
Äh, ja, theoretisch irgendwann im Oktober oder so, glaube ich.
Oder September?
Mal gucken, ob wir überhaupt welche kriegen.
Was darf's denn aus China?
Da sind ja eigentlich ganz viele, aber wir sind nicht wirklich dazu gekommen.
Was für Musik ist was für dich?
Äh, hauptsächlich Hardrock, Heavy Metal.
Beste.
Wobei, wie gesagt, ich geb mir auch mal die ein oder anderen
Hip-Hop-Geschichten, wobei die Deutschen nur zur Belustigung.
Das kann ich sicher.
Das kann ich nicht ernst nehmen, äh.
Also, das meiste habe da kann ich nicht ernst nehmen.
Und von den meisten musikalischen Qualitäten bin ich da auch nicht überzeugt.
Ich mein, bei Helene Fischer hast du wenigstens tatsächlich was zu schauen.
Anhören würd ich sie mir nicht unbedingt.
Findet ihr auch so wenig Azubi-Interessenten für die Informatikberufe?
Ist schwierig die letzten Jahre, ja.
Es sind auch bei uns relativ wenige.
Genau.
Goethe-Straße, Louis Vuitton-Store, Zahl die Kollektion Bar, Fick auf Sponsor.
Das sind die einzigen paar Zeilen Haftbefehle, die ich auswendig kann.
Informatik ist überall beliebt.
Ja, aber wir finden wenig.
Vielleicht wollen auch einfach wenige zu uns.
Kann auch sein.
Aber es sind in den letzten Jahren, zu den letzten zwei, drei Jahren, sind es erstaunlich wenig System-Integration-Azubis gewesen.
Was? Max, hast du schon gehört, dass Bird das Wort ist?
Ich bin 35, ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, was du mir sagen willst, V96.
Haha.
Hast du eben einen Ultraschall-Sensor bestellt?
Nee.
Wie kommst du drauf?
Das ist allerdings eine Sache, die tatsächlich auf meiner To-Do-Liste steht.
Für China-Einkäufe, die wir heute eigentlich machen wollten, nehm ich den Ultraschall-Sensor, der nur 3,3 Volt braucht.
Weil mein, den ich hab, braucht ja leider 5 Volt.
Und ich hab geguckt, der Nachfolger, der braucht eine 3,3.
Und ich hab das bei einem Shop in England bestellt.
Allerdings hat das jetzt eine Woche gedauert und kam nicht an.
Ich vermute mal, die haben mich scamast oder es ist irgendwo untergegangen oder so.
Ah, das ist aus Family Guy.
Okay, musste ich nicht.
Warum fragst du?
Eichelriss?
Bester Name, ey.
Hast du gerade was Tolles gefunden?
AliExpress.
Okay, gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, was er gefunden hat.
Da sieht man halt wieder China-Beste.
Guck mal, wie günstig der China-Kram ist.
Ja.
Hier bezahlst du vorneweg 3-4 Euro für den gleichen Sensor.
Wichtig ist, dass du den hier kriegst, ne?
Der ist 5 Volt.
Äh, das ist der gleiche.
Der ist 5 Volt und der ist 3,3 Volt.
Und nachdem man hier jetzt nicht auswählen kann, was man für einen Sensor haben will, ist es doof.
Oder kann man hier irgendwo auswählen, welchen der beiden Sensoren man haben will?
Warum darf ich eigentlich AliExpress aufmachen?
Ohne, dass ich mich einloggen muss.
Ah, jetzt muss ich mich wieder einloggen.
Okay.
Das ist Random Loot Boxen.
Ich bräuchte Chromium, womit ich das mit meinem alten Chrome synchen kann.
Boah, keine Ahnung, hab ich nie gemacht.
Chromium Installer, einfach mal gucken.
Chromium Windows Builds.
Hier, da.
Die hab ich auch.
Kannst du den Installer nehmen oder das Portable.
Wie du das da mit Chrome gesyncht kriegst, weiß ich nicht.
Ähm, ich glaube, das liegt daran, wenn man aus dem Unity Media Netz kommt.
Weil, beispielsweise auf der Arbeit muss ich das nicht.
Und ich glaube, vom Telekom Anschluss muss ich das auch nicht.
Also, wenn die hier jetzt eine Auswahl hätten, ne.
Ich mein, guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist schon massive billig, ne.
So, dann nimmt man, Versand aus China nimmt man am besten...
Die haben hier kein EU Priority Line.
Posti, Finnland.
Da bleibt ja eigentlich fast nur EMS Paket übrig.
Ich mein, es ist schon übertrieben, übertrieben billig, ne.
Ich mein, da kannst du hier 20 Sensoren holen für irgendwie 10 Euro.
Oder gibst du 15 Euro aus, hast 20 Sensoren inklusive Versand.
Das ist schon billig, ja.
Kann man sich Sachen...
Kann man sich Sachen aus China bestellen, ohne dass einem die Steckdosen explodieren?
Man muss ein bisschen drauf gucken...
Man muss ein bisschen drauf gucken, was man kauft.
Also, generell bei den meisten Sachen, wo 230 Volt drüber gehen, bin ich kein großartiger Fan von China Ware.
Jetzt mal von dieser Steckdosenleiste, die wir letztens geflasht haben, abgesehen.
Ähm, deswegen habe ich auch keine Sonoffs oder sowas.
Ähm...
Aber bei allem anderen kann man China Zeug, kann man China Zeug holen.
Achso ja, wo ich auch nicht China Zeug holen würde, sind Akkus und Batterien.
Das ist, das ist Crap von China Seiten.
Da kriegst du irgendeinen billigen Scheiß, der dir dann um die Ohren fliegt oder abfackelt oder sowas.
Das würde ich nicht machen.
Alle saß mit Lebensmittel in Büro und kommt.
Ja gut, das würde ich auch nicht machen.
Monka Smoke.
Wir brauchen unbedingt...
Gibt es ein Emote für Monka Smoke?
Monka Smoke.
Das sind meine Twitch...
Ha, lustig!
Wenn du nach Monka Smoke suchst, findest du Clips von meinen Streams.
Monka Smoke.
Ja, das ist fast, das ist ja fast schon sowas wie Monka Smoke.
Aber ich hätte gerne ein Emote, was wirklich Monka Smoke heißt.
Irgendwie halt so ein abfackeltes China Ding.
Wollte ich mal überlegen, vielleicht machen wir ein Emote.
Ähm, genau.
Übrigens, diese Sensoren standen bei mir auch jetzt auf der Kaufliste.
Die ich mir eigentlich holen wollte heute im Stream bei China Anbietern.
Also wie gesagt, habe ich noch keinen bestellt.
China kann ich mir nicht, das stimmt.
Jupp.
Falls man nicht übernommen wird nach der Ausbildung...
Wenn du nicht übernommen wirst nach der Ausbildung, kannst du genau das machen in der Zeit, was dich interessiert.
Weil...
Umso besser du dich auskennst in dem Bereich, der dich interessiert, umso einfacher kriegst du auch einen Job in dem Bereich, der dich interessiert.
Und dann profitieren ja alle davon.
Lerne einfach das in dem Bereich, was dich interessiert.
Generell, ich würde nur Sachen lernen.
So privat und wenn es von mir aus geht.
Sachen, die mich interessieren.
Weil ansonsten fehlt mir der Antrieb.
Ich könnte beispielsweise nie im Leben sagen, hey ich weiß, Kobol Programmierer werden gut bezahlt.
Ich lerne Kobol.
Das würde ich dann machen.
Wofür braucht man denn einen Ultraschallsensor?
Ja, gucken ob du schwanger bist.
Was sonst?
Apropos, das hatten wir gerade.
Nein.
Einen Ultraschallsensor...
Einen Ultraschallsensor kannst du zum Beispiel verwenden, um zu gucken, wie voll ein Wassertank ist.
Oder als Abstandsmesser...
Abstandsmesser, wie weit du von einem Objekt entfernt bist.
Oder aber, wofür ich ihn verwenden will, im Briefkasten bzw. im Zeitungsrohr, ob was drin steckt.
Dafür kann man zum Beispiel einen Ultraschallsensor verwenden.
Ob was im Rohr steckt.
Leute, Leute, Leute, jetzt geht es wieder los hier.
Kannst du den Sensor nicht irgendwie extra powern?
Hä?
Ich habe eine Batterie für 3,3 Volt.
Ich könnte, ich könnte das, ich könnte, ich könnte so ein Step-Up-Dings dazwischen stecken.
Ja, das würde funktionieren.
Also, Problem mit dem 5-Volt-Sensor ist, ich habe nicht so einfach einen Pin mit 5 Volt.
Da müsste ich so einen Step-Up-Converter dazwischen machen, dann aus 3,3 Volt 5 Volt macht.
Problem ist dann wiederum die Datenleitung.
Also für die GPS.
Also für die GPIO-Pins.
Die sind dann auch 5 Volt und das Board braucht 3,3 Volt.
Das heißt, ich müsste für diesen Sensor erstmal 3,3 Volt zu 5 Volt konvertieren.
Und dann die Datenleitung wieder von 5 Volt auf 3,3 Volt.
Das ist das Board nicht kaputt.
Das lohnt sich nicht.
Ich brauche, und außerdem braucht das auch noch Strom.
Ja, aber wozu soll ich das machen?
Ich kaufe mir einfach für 50 Cent einen 3,3 Volt Sensor.
Ja, aber selbst das, das braucht alles und nur die Strom im Batteriebetrieb.
Das Beste ist ein 3,3 Volt Sensor.
Wubblos und Chat.
Kann jemand einen dünnen DNS-Anbieter empfehlen oder gibt es andere Möglichkeiten?
Ja, ich kann dir einen dünnen DNS-Anbieter empfehlen.
Den verwende ich selbst.
DuckDNS.
Beste.
Kostenlos.
Unterstützt die wichtigsten Sachen zum Anmelden.
GitHub, Reddit, Twitter, Google.
Total einfach.
Und lässt sich super easy mit Curl aktualisieren.
Unterstützt auch TXT Records.
Das heißt, du kannst sogar Let's Encrypt Zertifikate easy beantragen.
Beste.
Ja, das ist mal ein High-End-Logo, oder?
Für einen Dienst.
Absolutes High-End-Logo.
Das ist übrigens auch mal so ein Dienst, wo man sich überlegen kann, wenn man den verwendet.
Weil der ist komplett kostenlos.
So ein Dienst, wo man sich überlegen kann, ob man den Typ nicht mal supportet.
Mit irgendwie 1, 2 Euro im Monat.
Oder irgendwie kleiner Donation oder sowas.
Ich meine, allein schon seine Sauberkosten.
Und dass er ein bisschen was über hat, wäre ja nicht verkehrt.
Ja, den kann ich aber empfehlen.
Wie sieht es mit Partnerbewerbung aus?
Noch nicht raus.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ich mache das auch.
Diesmal mache ich das.
Diesmal mache ich wirklich Partnerantrag.
Wofür braucht man nun?
Haben wir schon beantwortet?
Langsam erwarten wir?
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Spannungsteile hatten wir auch gerade.
Nextcloud nichts mehr im Weg.
Jop.
Wobei ich da aufpassen würde.
Also ich würde meine Nextcloud-Instanz auf gar keinen Fall öffentlich ins Internet hängen.
Sollte das mal wirklich irgendwelche Security-Probleme haben.
Also das PHP oder Nextcloud an sich.
Da können die Leute direkt auf dein Zeug zugreifen aus dem Internet.
Von wöchentlich streamen habe ich nichts gesagt.
Ich habe nur gesagt, dass ich mich partnermäßig bewerben werde.
Man muss nicht unbedingt wöchentlich streamen, wenn man Partner ist.
Allerdings ist es natürlich blöd zu sagen, auch rein aus User-Sicht.
Also Twitch erwartet schon eine gewisse regelmäßige Sache.
Allerdings musst du ja auch, bevor du dich als Partner bewirbst, erstmal eine gewisse Zeit gestreamt haben.
Und in der Regel bist du einmal Partner, immer Partner, seien du baust.
Übertrieben.
Scheiße.
Zumindest hat mir das mal jemand so erklärt.
Ähm.
Aber es ist natürlich auch für die Zuschauer kacke, wenn es dann welche gibt, die dich supporten.
Da hast du ja auch gefühlt zumindest eine gewisse Verpflichtung.
Äh.
Kannst du nicht erst wie ein halbes Jahr dich verdrücken.
Ähm.
Ja, wie gesagt, also ich würde mein Nextcloud auf keinen Fall irgendwie direkt ins Internet hängen.
Wenn ich überhaupt.
Also das beste ist.
Wenn du von außen drauf zugreifen willst.
Und Kontrolle über deine Endgeräte hast, mach ein VPN.
Das ist das einfachste.
Ist egal welches, aber mach ein VPN.
Das ist easy.
Das ist sicher.
Da würde ich mir keine Gedanken drüber machen.
Oder keine Gedanken zu machen.
VPN daheim einwählen und auf den Nextcloud zugreifen.
Das ist so sicher, da würde ich mir keine Gedanken zu machen.
Das würde ich auch bedenkenlos empfehlen.
Würde ich auch bedenkenlos selbst so machen.
Ähm.
Wenn du nicht unbedingt Kontrolle über die Endgeräte hast.
Ja, wenn du dich zum Beispiel mal von dem, keine Ahnung, von deinem Arbeitsnotebook oder so einloggen willst oder so.
Irgendwas, was halt nicht dein Endgerät ist.
Da würde ich mir überlegen.
Als erstes muss das unbedingt sein.
Und wenn ja, würde ich zumindest einen Reverse Proxy da vorstellen.
Der Authentifizierungsgedöns macht.
Und dahinter dann die Nextcloud.
Die im Zweifelsfall nochmal Authentifizierung macht, wenn es sein muss.
Aber direkt ins Internet hängen würde ich es nicht.
Ich würde da zumindest einen, sagen wir mal, einen Nginx Reverse Proxy oder sowas da vorstellen.
Reicht da der Fritzdienst vom VPN?
Ja klar, besser als nix.
Wenn die Endgeräte alle dein sind, mach VPN.
Und wenn du nicht das von der Fritzbox verwenden willst, kannst du dir auch ohne Probleme dein Raspberry dahinter stellen an die Fritzbox.
Und ähm, leitest den Port weiter über die Fritzbox an den Raspberry für VPN.
Und machst, ähm, VPN auf den Raspberry.
Ja, gut.
Ja, okay, du kannst nicht alles verwenden.
Ich meinte alles heute gängige.
Kannst auch irgendeine China VPN Lösung verwenden.
Also im Prinzip gibt es eigentlich ja nur zwei Sachen zur Auswahl, die verbreitet sind.
Das OpenVPN und IPsec.
Und jetzt neuerdings auch recht angesagt WireGuard.
Niki ist noch auf dem Rad, er hofft ich bleibe länger on.
Äh, Niki, ich glaube das wird, äh, das wird nix mehr.
22 Uhr spätestens ist Schluss, weil ich ins Bett muss, morgen wieder 5 vor 45 aufstehen.
Aber das Schöne ist, ihr wisst ja, 4 Tage Arbeitswoche nur.
Also immer 4 Tage nur.
Das ist zwar eine der besten Entscheidungen ever.
Das würde ich jederzeit wieder so machen.
Schenkst du dem Grill dieses Jahr wieder was zu Weihnachten?
Vielleicht.
Mal gucken.
Ich hatte mit dem Grill jetzt schon ne Weile nix mehr zu tun.
Ich glaube das Grill war ein bisschen davon abgeschreckt, dass ich, äh, so, wie nennt man das so, weiß nicht ob man sagen kann, so wenig interessiert, so, so, antisozial bin.
Dass mich zwischenmenschliche Sachen nicht so, äh, nicht so im Fokus stehen bei mir, ja.
Ähm, äh, hab ich mich jetzt schon öfters drüber ausgelassen, muss ich jetzt heute nicht nochmal machen.
Hab ich auch schon gesagt.
Ja, genau.
VPN.
Äh, oder zumindest mal ne Reverse-Proxy dazwischen.
Wo man sich dann überlegen kann, was man denn für Authentifizierungsmaßnahmen nimmt.
Reverse-Proxy mit Basic-Auth dazwischen ist immer noch besser, wie das Ding direkt ins Internet stellen.
Reverse-Proxy, Basic-Auth ist so, ist eigentlich super easy eingerichtet.
Und im Zweifelsfall macht mehr noch was.
Im Zweifelsfall macht mehr nochmal Authentifizierung gegen die, gegen die Nextcloud dann, äh, dahinter.
Ich dachte jetzt, wo du so viel streamst, wirst du regelmäßig streamen.
Ich bin ja noch ein bisschen hin und her gerissen.
Ich, äh, das muss ich jetzt vielleicht an der Stelle mal erzählen mit dem, mit dem, mit dem Stream.
Ich finde das sehr nice, die ganzen Technik-Streams, die wir machen.
Und ich finde es auch unglaublich nice, dass so viele Leute immer zugucken.
Das ist ja nun wirklich kein, kein Thema.
Was die breite Masse anspricht, ne?
Also, wenn ich hier irgendwelche ESP32-Sachen programmier oder China, China-Technik-Kram kaufe oder hier irgendwie C Sharp was programmier,
das ist ja nix so für den Mainstream im Endeffekt.
Ähm, ursprünglich angefangen mit diesen Technik-Streams hab ich ja, weil es keine Games gibt, die mich interessieren.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll, so richtig mal angenommen.
Es kommt jetzt Bad Company 3 raus.
Und ich find's übelst nice.
Dann, dann werd ich wahrscheinlich auch wieder ein bisschen Bad Company 3 spielen.
Was man sich halt auch überlegen muss, ist, Streams kosten natürlich viel Zeit.
Das heißt, das ist ne Sache, die mach ich nur, wenn, also auf jeden Fall nur, wenn ich, wenn ich, wie, wenn, wenn die Zeit halt sich für mich nicht irgendwie anfühlt, als wär sie verschwendet.
Was sie ja nicht macht, ja.
Ähm, und ich denk halt auch mal so, das Publikum, was man erreichen kann mit so Technik-Streams,
ist begrenzt in Deutschland.
Ziemlich begrenzt, ja.
Also, ich hab, manchmal hab ich so in der Spitze 200 Zuschauer, ähm, bei so Technik-Zeug.
Ich denk, allzu viel mehr wird's nicht.
Weil ich glaub, es gibt einfach, vor allem auf Twitch gucken auch nicht so viele.
Wo ich immer relativ viele Zuschauer hab, da hatten wir glaub ich ja mal sogar 500 oder irgendwie sowas, war ja mal in, in der Spitze, ne.
War...
Als wir E3-Streams gemacht haben und...
E3-Streams und was andere war Gamescom, Pressekonferenz und sowas.
Da haben immer, da haben richtig viele geguckt.
Da hab ich, da hab ich schon so ein bisschen, äh, gemonka, shaked, äh, so viele Leute, die dazu geguckt haben.
Aber so diese reinen Technik-Sachen interessieren jetzt ja auch nicht so extrem viele.
Face-Reveal, 20.000 Zuschauer, Quatsch.
Das interessiert eigentlich kein Mensch, wie ich ausschaue.
Außerdem gibt's sogar Videos, wo man mich sieht.
Äh, äh, WireGuard hab ich mir schon aufgeschrieben, wollen wir in einem der nächsten Streams machen.
Hab ich mir schon aufgeschrieben.
Hatten wir schon, hatten wir auch schon.
Welchen Raspberry empfiehlst du?
Den künstlichsten, der ausreicht für das, was du machen willst.
Was willst du denn machen?
Was willst du machen?
Ähm...
Niki ist jetzt da.
Von wann bis wann arbeitest du?
Ähm...
Ein bisschen unterschiedlich, je nachdem welcher Tag das ist.
Also montags arbeite ich gar nicht.
Äh, dienstags, mittwochs, donnerstags...
...arbeite ich meistens von so 7.10 bis 15.30 Uhr.
Und freitags meistens so bis von 7.15 bis 13.30 bis 14.30 Uhr.
Was ist dein Job, Ausrufezeichen, Beruf?
Ich werbe nur als kleiner Serverersatz, Steuerung von Sachen.
Also wenn du wirklich einen kleinen, kleinen, kleinen Serverersatz suchst...
...und wenn du wirklich nur Sachen steuern willst...
...dann würde ich mir einen Raspberry Zero W nehmen.
Das ist der kleinste...
...der schwächste...
...allerdings der kompakteste...
...und auch den, den man...
...finde ich, am einfachsten betreiben kann.
Der passt in jede Ecke, einen Zero W.
Der ist aber nicht schnell...
...im Vergleich zu anderen.
Und ich glaube auch nur einen 800 MHz Kern.
Also der Zero ist wirklich nicht der schnellste.
Für VPN? Es geht nicht um VPN.
Er hat geschrieben, es geht um kleiner Serverersatzsteuerung von Sachen.
Für VPN würde ich kein Zero nehmen.
Mein Gehalt ist dafür zu privat.
Ich weiß selbst gar nicht, wie viel ich genau gerade kriege.
Ich rechte das immer nur nach, wenn es gerade darum geht.
Aber es reicht auf jeden Fall.
Mit YouTube verdiene ich ja aktuell nicht wirklich was.
YouTube habe ich diesen Monat glaube ich 35 Euro oder so gekriegt.
Oder 35 Dollar.
Was hast du für einen Abschluss?
Ich habe mal irgendwann 2000, frag mich nicht.
Eins, ich weiß nicht, ewig her.
Habe ich mittlere Reife gemacht.
Danach habe ich mich ziemlich viel in allen möglichen Sachen rumgetrieben.
Ich habe ja sogar mal angefangen Bürokaufmann zu lernen.
So BWL Shit.
Wo ich dann irgendwann gemerkt habe, Alter ist das ein Krack.
Da habe ich gar keinen Bock.
Ich habe relativ lang gebraucht, bis ich dann da gelandet bin, was ich jetzt mache.
Ne, ne, es ist nicht so viel, dass ich die Zahlen nicht im Kopf habe.
Aber ich weiß es nicht genau.
Das ändert sich ja auch immer mal, je nach Tarifvertrag oder Bonusgeschichte.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Außerdem ist es nichts, was ich großartig breit treten will.
Wahrscheinlich im Streaming.
Muss ich mir mal überlegen, was du erzählen willst.
Vier Tage, wo musst du dich bewerben?
Das ist kein Problem.
Das kannst du eigentlich bewerben.
Das ist ein Problem, das die meisten Arbeitgeber heutzutage machen.
Und umso jünger die Leute sind, umso mehr ist das für die wichtig.
Es gibt auch Umfragen zu.
Und viele Leute sagen heutzutage, hey, arbeiten ist nicht mehr alles.
Und ich finde das gerade cool, dass das immer mehr jüngere Leute sagen.
Weil, wenn man sich das mal ehrlich anguckt, ich glaube, es gibt niemand.
Angenommen, heute ist so euer letzter Tag und ihr wisst, in fünf Minuten kratzt ihr ab.
Ich glaube, kaum einer wird sagen, ja.
Ich habe in meinem Leben noch mal mehr gearbeitet.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute werden sagen, hey, hätte ich mal mehr Zeit gehabt für keine Ahnung, Kinder, Frau, Familie.
Einfach machen, wo ich Bock drauf habe.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich, was die meisten Leute denken werden.
Deswegen finde ich es gut, dass gerade jüngere Leute mittlerweile sagen, es ist ihnen besonders wichtig, dass das alles irgendwie schön im Einklang ist.
Deswegen vier Tage Woche ist eigentlich kein Problem.
Die meisten Arbeitgeber haben damit keine Probleme.
Und also heutzutage wenig Probleme, zumindest im Technikumfeld.
Und außerdem darf da so ohne weiteres ein Arbeitgeber auch gar nichts dabei dagegen sagen.
Also der kann dich nicht einfach rausschmeißen, weil du sagst, Herr Chef, ich will gerne Teilzeit arbeiten.
Natürlich sollte man gucken, dass man mit seinem Chef da irgendwie eine ordentliche Lösung findet.
Wir sind zum Programmieren gekommen.
Boah, was war denn das Erste, was ich damals programmiert habe?
Und warum?
Das habe ich bestimmt schon mal erzählt, aber ich kann mich gerade nicht daran erinnern.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Vielleicht weiß es einer, weil ich es schon mal im Stream erzählt habe.
Also angefangen habe ich damals mit.
Ich habe mir mal ein Python Buch gekauft, schon ewig her.
Das war noch uralt Python Version.
Davor habe ich auch ein bisschen mal mit C rumgespielt.
Aber so richtig angefangen habe ich eigentlich damals, als ich ein bisschen.
Bisschen.
Unter Windows rumgebastelt habe und mir das war damals.
Visual Studio 2003 oder 2005 war das, glaube ich.
Da gab es noch C Sharp Express und sowas.
Und da habe ich mir ein C Sharp Buch geholt und habe angefangen.
Das war das so, wo ich wirklich angefangen habe, richtig programmieren zu lernen.
Und ich muss sagen, und das haben wahrscheinlich.
Es haben wahrscheinlich viele und wahrscheinlich haben sie gleichermaßen wenige.
Ähm.
Die ihre erste Sprache, mit der sie angefangen haben zu programmieren, für immer für die tollste Sprache halten oder gerade Leute, die mit sowas angefangen haben, C++, die das für immer hassen.
Kannst du ein Python Buch empfehlen?
Nee, nee, habe ich zu lange nichts, nichts gelesen zu.
Na Flo, wenn du schon breit genug bist, dann ist ja alles gut.
Welche Reverse Proxy empfiehlst du einfach aufzulassen?
Also ich nehme immer Nginx.
Nginx ist nicht der einfachste zu konfigurieren.
Dafür kann er viel.
Was ziemlich beliebt ist in letzter Zeit, was ich immer wieder lese, was ich aber selbst noch nie verwendet habe, ist, ähm, ist, oh, wie heißt der Kram, Cuddy und Traffic und ein paar verwenden auch HA-Proxy, aber ich glaube, Cuddy und Traffic sind so die angesagten Hype-Dinger zurzeit.
Ich persönlich schwöre auf Nginx und ich verwende eigentlich für alles, wo man einen Reverse Proxy oder einen Web-Server braucht, Nginx.
Nginx schreibt man übrigens so, fragt mich nicht, ups, fragt mich nicht warum, also, weil Nginx, aber ich verschreibe mich jedes Mal.
Metro Last Light, habe ich immer noch nicht gekauft.
Stream einfach, worauf du Bock hast.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Fett für viel, hatten wir schon.
Wo ich richtig hyped wäre, ist ein Format, bei dem du dir von irgendwelchen Technik-Convention-Streams machst.
Gibt fast jede Woche irgendein Event.
Du meinst, dass wir uns zusammen die Livestreams angucken oder was?
Ja, wenn euch das interessiert.
Ich gucke eh relativ viel in der Richtung.
Schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Das könnten wir echt mal machen, wenn irgendwas ist.
Ja, zum Beispiel, okay, Apple Developer-Konferenz-Geschiss war gerade erst, aber dazu hätten wir super einen Stream machen können.
Und da können wir uns wieder anhören.
Die most awesome experience of awesomeness.
Oder, Moment, Clip-Wobblers.
Ja, das ist das.
Ja, das war gestern, war es so.
Oblos, Luftschachtstelzer.
Achtung, kommt der krasse Luftschachtstelzer.
Der krasse Luftschachtstelzer.
Das ist doch der Luftschachtstelzer.
Was ich euch eigentlich zeigen wollte, gestern haben wir uns ein bisschen was von der Bild angeguckt, ja.
Und das war halt, das war halt übelst, übelst cringe, fremdschämend.
Und das war halt, das war halt übelst cringe, fremdschämend.
Das ist so ein Fail.
Das ist so, das tut, das tut echt richtig weh.
Alter, du hast an was gezockt auf Twitch.
Ja, sogar heute Morgen, wir haben sogar heute Morgen was gespielt.
So, also ab und zu spiele ich mal was, ja.
Das machen wir, das finde ich gut.
Falls du da, falls du irgendwelche aktuellen Vorschläge,
hast, was es so gibt, sag ruhig
Bescheid, weil es kann durchaus sein, ich gucke
zwar relativ viel, aber meistens gucke ich Zusammenfassungen
danach, weil ich gar nicht mitkriege, dass
gerade irgendwas live ist. Also hier
an die Patrick, ohne dass dir irgendwas auffällt,
kannst du mir das ruhig im Discord schreiben oder hier
im Stream schreiben oder auf Twitter schreiben oder generell
könnt ihr mir das immer auf Twitter schreiben, wenn irgendwo eine
Veranstaltung mit Livestream
ist, was wir
uns zusammen im Stream angucken wollen.
Ich meine, die großen Sachen irgendwie wie
E3 Gamescom ist jetzt demnächst
auch wieder, mal gucken, ob es da irgendwas gibt.
Oder irgendwie Build von Microsoft, diese Apple
Developer-Konferenz, klar, kriege ich auch mit.
Aber es gibt bestimmt noch jede Menge anderes Zeug,
was ich verpasse.
Was ist mein Shop-Ausrufezeichen-Beruf?
Hatten wir schon. Abschluss hatten wir
auch schon.
Wie hast du die 4-Tage-Woche ausgehandelt
mit deinem Geld? Verdienst du jetzt einfach einen Tag
mit? Ja, exakt.
Genau so.
Wobei es halt in der Summe, was
unten rauskommt,
gar nicht so viel weniger ist.
Kein Uni-Abschluss, nein.
Ich kriege Dinger per Payspin geschickt.
Achso, das hatten wir doch
vorhin schon mal.
Ach nee, du hast es jetzt erweitert.
Büro, Schreibtisch.
Also, hat sich beim Discord
was geändert? Nee, es gibt noch keinen Discord.
Naja, das mit dem Verdienen habe ich jetzt ja schon was zu
gesagt, dass ich mir da erstmal Gedanken...
Wie kann man am schnellsten
programmieren? Ich finde,
Coden ist ein ganz schlimmes
Wort. Ich sage immer programmieren.
Weil beim Programmieren
geht es nicht nur um das Schreiben von
Source-Code. Da geht es eigentlich
zu 90% ums Nachdenken
und
danach den Kram irgendwie auf Papier
in den Editor bringen.
Niki, wir gucken uns das dann...
Falls du den nächsten Stream noch was
hast, was wir uns
angucken sollen, können wir uns das dann angucken.
Weil, wie gesagt, ich muss um 22 Uhr pennen.
Proggen! Proggen ist natürlich auch was.
Äh,
drei Tage.
Ja, nein, das ist...
Dice-Kräuter hat voll und ganz recht.
Freizeit generell.
Sachen, die man macht,
weil man sie selbst machen will,
ist im Prinzip das Beste.
Und letztendlich, wenn man sich überlegt,
um was geht es im Leben, bestimmt nicht den ganzen Tag zu arbeiten,
sondern eigentlich
das zu machen, worauf man Bock hat.
So viel wie möglich,
so viel es einem irgendwie quasi erlaubt
ist, das zu machen,
worauf man Bock hat.
Und wenn es danach geht, sollte man vielleicht das Heiraten und Kinderkriegen vermeiden.
Dann kann man relativ wenig machen, worauf man Bock hat.
Aber das muss jeder selbst wissen.
Außerdem habe ich schon mal gesagt, ich mag keine Menschen und ich mag noch weniger Kinder.
Für mich stellt sich die Frage aktuell also eh nicht.
Ähm...
Tja, wie kann man am schnellsten programmieren in Python lernen?
Tja...
Wie kann man am schnellsten programmieren lernen?
Ich würde sagen,
eine Mischung aus
sich ein ordentliches Buch kaufen,
das ist für mich immer noch das Beste, wie man neue Technik lernt,
ähm...
Webcasts gucken,
vielleicht den ein oder anderen Online-Kurs machen,
der was taugt,
ähm...
und dabei auf jeden Fall sich überlegen,
was man...
...
...ob es ein Projekt gibt,
was man wirklich umsetzen möchte.
Weil ich meine, es hat ja vielleicht einen Sinn,
dass du sagst, hey, ich möchte jetzt unbedingt Python lernen, weil ich möchte...
...keine Ahnung, irgendwas machen.
Ich möchte...
...TensorFlow...
...irgendwelche Bilderkennung machen oder so.
Irgendwas ist ja gerade angesagt, oder?
Vielleicht hast du irgendwas im Kopf, wo du sagst, hey, das will ich unbedingt machen...
...und ich weiß nicht wie.
Das ist eigentlich so die beste Motivation, das zu lernen,
weil man nämlich...
...dem...
...immer näher kommt, was man eigentlich machen will.
Und dann halt, wie gesagt, eine Mischung, ein ordentliches Buch, Webcasts...
...und halt nicht rein beschallen lassen, sondern halt ausprobieren.
Weil beim Ausprobieren fallen einem halt viele Sachen auf,
warum sie so sind, wie sie sind.
Minecraft-Plugins.
Genau!
Das ist ein super Beispiel.
Genau sowas meine ich.
Ähm...
Hier, der Zagor...
Ach, da hast du eigentlich nett hinten dran, wegen irgendwie .NET oder...
...oder sowas.
Also, Zagor...
...Zagor Nets, äh...
...war der Meinung, okay, er braucht eine Minecraft-Plugin...
...wie mache ich das am besten?
Und das ist die beste...
...die beste Motivation...
...programmieren zu lernen.
Wenn du sagst, ah, ich hätte gerne die...
...ich spiele Minecraft und hätte gerne die und die Funktion...
...da gibt es nichts für und ich würde gerne Minecraft-Plugin programmieren...
...dann ist es relativ einfach.
Du sagst, okay...
...Minecraft-Server...
...was verbrauche ich da für eine Sprache...
...in was macht man das?
Aha!
Java, also muss ich Java lernen.
Easy!
Entscheidung gefallen.
Weil ich gar nicht weiß, ob die neuen Sachen noch in Java sind.
Ja, das haben wir beantwortet.
Was?
In 60 Jahren stirbt er...
...alleine alt.
Ähm...
...ja, so wie ich mich kenne, kann das schon sein.
Allerdings, ich bin nicht alleine.
In 60 Jahren mache ich Livestream, wenn ich dann...
...ich kratze dann irgendwann...
...im Livestream ab.
Oder...
...oder auf YouTube oder so.
Während gerade gebasht wird.
Da wird gerade COD...
...2075 gebasht.
Und dann reg ich mich auf, dass ich across the map...
...getomahawked wurde und dann gebe ich den Löffel ab.
Und dann spammt der ganze Chat F, ey.
Das kann ich mir richtig vorstellen.
Was passiert mit deinem YouTube-Channel, wenn ich den...
Alter, Leute, ey!
Ich bin zwar nächsten Monat 35, aber...
...ich werde nicht demnächst ins Gras beißen.
Ich habe es sogar abgenommen wieder.
Jetzt schon...
...7 Wochen in Folge.
Ähm...
Kannst du...
...den Python-Buch kann ich dir empfehlen.
Hatten wir schon.
Hast du den Code für den Chat-Code?
Zeugst du denn zur Zeit überhaupt noch irgendwas?
Ja, heute Morgen haben wir ein bisschen...
...Amit Evil gespielt.
Ansonsten fehlen mir tatsächlich Games...
...die man spielen kann.
Last Light Summer Sale.
Ja, vielleicht wird es doch mal Zeit.
Nie das Bullshit-Bingo, ja.
Bullshit-Bingo...
Discord haben wir schon.
Broggen...
Haha, der iSquad, das ist die...
...der Plan schlechthin.
Einfach gehen lernen, ob die schon 18 sind.
Genau das.
Kennst du Sprache, SCL und ST?
Structured Control Language Bestimmung...
...Strukturierte...
Was?
Strukturierter Text...
...klingt für mich ein bisschen wie Markdown so.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
SCL.
Das ist...
...Glock.
Strukturierter Text.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie...
...Emacs Org Mode.
Ist das sowas wie...
...Pascal?
Oder ist das sowas wie...
...ein Struktogramm in...
...in...
...keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Ne, kenn ich nicht.
Ja, kriegst du dann.
Wenn du den dann...
...noch brauchen kannst zu dem...
...in dem Jahr...
...dann ist das aber wahrscheinlich nicht mehr OP.
Hat deine Waage...
...auch ein Webinterface?
Ne.
Die Waage, die ich hab, ist...
...sowas von oldschool.
Die hat noch nicht mal eine digitale Anzeige.
Die hat ein Gewicht, was man hin und her schiebt.
Die ist...
...das ist nicht mehr oldschool.
Das ist retro.
Gilt das Stream als Testament?
Da müssen sich dann andere mit beschäftigen.
Testo Moris. Aha, Pascal.
Ich dachte mir schon. Sieht ein bisschen aus wie Pascal.
Ähm...
Also hier.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was du mir damit sagen wolltest.
Hast du den Code für den Chatcode?
Waage, Webinterface, nope.
Skinny, Max, Inc.
Also, wenn das in diesem Tempo weitergeht, schon.
Aber ich geh mal davon aus, das wird auch weniger.
Ähm...
Könntest du nicht mal dein Meme-Tool umbauen,
dass der Twitch-Stream das Meme-Tool übernehmen kann?
Ähm...
Ich will ja schon die ganze Zeit
das Meme-Tool nochmal neu ordentlich basteln.
Das wäre natürlich
ein schöner, ein schöner, ein schönes...
Nein, nicht Plugin, eine schöne Funktion,
dass man sagen könnte,
Twitch-Chat, äh...
Twitch-Chat kann Emotes einblenden.
HTML und CSS
beste Programmiersprache?
Generell HTML, CSS...
Beste.
Walla, beste.
Beste ist Pascal.
Musst du dein Hightech-Klo patchen?
Leider hat mein Klo
keine ordentliche
Schnittstelle, um sich da irgendwie
dran zu...
...attachen.
Habe ich mir auch schon überlegt,
ob es nicht vielleicht eine Möglichkeit gäbe,
dass ich da ein ESP8266
oder sowas neben, unter die Abdeckung vom Klo
mache und vielleicht auslesen kann,
wie der Füllstand ist
von der Spülflüssigkeit
oder wie die Temperatur ist
oder wie
der Filterstand ist.
Leider habe ich dazu keine Möglichkeit
gefunden bisher.
Hat dein Klo LoRa?
Das ist zwar schon ein recht
smartes Klo mit vielen Komfortfunktionen,
allerdings ist es leider nicht so modern,
dass man es flashen kann oder
irgendwie mit einer API auslesen kann.
Das wäre natürlich extrem nice.
Ja.
Das habe ich übrigens schon aufgeschrieben.
Mit dem Meme-Tool.
Ja, achso, den...
Hast du den Code für den Chat...
Ach, du meinst den Source-Code vom
PPGA-Board.
Das könnte ich eigentlich pushen, ja.
Das ist ja mehr oder weniger
rechtfertig eigentlich.
Und auch recht übersichtlich.
Okay.
Musst du dann halt...
hatten wir schon...
Das ist die Sharp.
Da unten ist es ja noch ein bisschen
Dota und ein bisschen JavaScript.
Und natürlich sind Twitch-Emojis
ist das programmiert.
Industrie hab ich keine Ahnung von.
Ähm, das ist der Grund, warum
ich auch kein Sonoff verwende.
Ich trau den Dingern nicht richtig.
Zumal man dort die Kabel für aufschneiden
muss und rein machen.
Irgendwie mag ich das ganze
Sonoff-Konzept nicht.
Dann hol ich mir lieber eine Steckdosenleiste,
die ich flashen kann.
Ähm, also das Ding hat sowas, was aussieht wie eine serielle Schnittstelle.
Aber ich habe dazu nichts, nichts gefunden.
Ich glaube 8000 plus ist es.
Ja.
Ähm, ich habe dazu...
Ne, da zeigt nicht die Technik.
Genau, hier neben hat es so, das kann man an der Seite aufmachen, da ist die Technik drin.
Ähm, was noch am ehesten funktioniert, ist glaube ich die Fernbedienung anzapfen.
Hä, das ist kein Witz mit dem Klo.
Also so wirklich smart ist das Klo nicht.
Das hat nur schön viele Funktionen.
Kann man heizen lassen, das hat einen Föhn, das hat, ähm, also Trockenpusten.
Das hat Luftabsaugung, verschiedene Profile.
Den Winkel, wie das das Wasser sprühen soll.
Mehr Wasser, weniger Wasser.
Äh, Zeug.
Ich absenke Automatik.
Also ich glaube am weitesten kommt man noch damit, wenn man die Fernbedienung irgendwie anzapft.
Warum braucht man sowas, weil es sehr angenehm ist.
Das braucht man erst, wenn man es mal hatte, dann merkt man, oder besser gesagt, wenn man es mal hatte und nicht mehr hat, merkt man, dass einem was fehlt.
Seitdem ich das Klo habe, gehe ich eigentlich nirgends woanders mehr aufs Klo.
Wenn es sich nicht vermeiden lässt.
Man findet leider hier kein Bild mit der Technik.
Das hat so nichts.
Hier sieht man schon ein bisschen was nebendran, was aussieht wie eine serielle Schnittstelle.
Ah!
Ja, hier sieht man schon ein bisschen was.
Ich suche mal nach GitHub.
Ja, Brandgefahr, habe ich euch ja erzählt, wo sie davor gewarnt haben, dass das Klo brennen kann.
Klo hat schlechte Bewertung.
Guck mal!
Der hat, der hat ein Cichard-Programm, wo man sich zu seiner, zu seinem Klo verbinden kann.
Ist doch ganz interessant.
Vielleicht funktioniert das auch bei meinem Klo.
Das muss ich mir mal speichern.
Im Raspberry, okay.
Und wie verbindet er sich?
Bluetooth!
Ah, fuck, ne.
Mein Klo hat kein Bluetooth.
Das ist zu alt.
Is anal shower running?
Reaktale.
Nope, hier ist nichts mit Injection.
Auto-Refresh für das, das Board auto-refreshed.
Was meinst du denn, warum da hinten dran Refresh gleich 0 steht?
Da steht dran, dass es nicht Refreshed.
Ansonsten Refreshed das jede Sekunde.
Aber von meinem ganzen Smart Home Gedöns, kennst du HyperJS ja.
Von meinem ganzen Smart Home Gedöns ist eigentlich die Steuerung vom Klo für mich aktuell das uninteressanteste, weil
das Klo musst du prinzipiell nur steuern, wenn du hier drauf bist und dann hast du die Fernbedienung und die Knöpfe an der Seite.
Ähm, ich wüsste nicht, was ich da machen will mit.
Und wenn, dann würde ich versuchen, irgendetwas zu machen.
Versuchen irgendwie mir eine Fernbedienung zu besorgen und ähm, versuchen irgendwie die Fernbedienung anzuzapfen.
Oder vielleicht ist sogar ganz einfach und die Fernbedienung sind ganz normale Infrarot-Codes, die geschickt werden.
Dann könnte man, das ist nämlich ziemlich easy, äh, einfach mal mitschneiden und, und mit einem ESP und einem Infrarot-Sender nachbauen.
Und wenn, dann ist das alles in Ordnung.
Was man da halt nicht mitbekommt, ist zum Beispiel, ob der Filter leer ist oder sowas.
Aber da könnte man das auch viel einfacher machen, weil wenn der Filter leer ist, leuchtet ein LED rot an der Seite.
Da könnte ich einfach so einen Fotosensor dran machen.
Kostet ja auch nur 20 Cent so ein Ding.
Dann krieg ichs auch mit.
Kurz die Klimaanlage anmachen, um schon wieder zu warm.
Ähm, keine Ahnung, das hatten wir ja schon.
Wenn man das nicht flashen kann, ist es kein Klo.
Ich würde eher sagen, wenn man es nicht fluschen kann, also nicht flaschen kann, dann ist es kein Klo.
Oh, oh.
Beste.
Was sage ich?
Äh, also bisher ist bei allem, nicht nur bei Grills, bei allen ist das Klo super angekommen.
Das hat ja sogar eine extra Girl-Funktion, das Klo.
Eine, wie heißt, eine Lady-Dusche-Funktion.
Die sind extra drinnen.
Hat sogar einen extra Knopf dafür.
Habt ihr doch gerade auf der Fernbedienung gesehen.
Einen extra Knopf.
Wenn du bei der Arbeit aufs Klo musst, gehst du dann zuerst nach Hause.
Ich versuche tatsächlich, sofern es möglich ist, nur daheim aufs Klo zu gehen, seitdem ich da mein High-End-Klo habe.
Jaja.
Ey, in der Bahn nie.
Da habe ich lieber Bauchkrämpfe, wenn ich so dringend kacken muss.
Bevor ich in der Bahn...
... in der Bahn kacken gehe.
Das war klar.
Das Thema gefällt Twitch-Chat natürlich wieder richtig gut.
Bahnflame.
Mein letztes Video auf dem Channel ist doch Bahnflame.
Nee.
Mein letztes Video auf dem Channel ist Nvidia-Flame.
Ja, kenne ich.
Das ist ein JavaScript-Terminal.
Hast du auch ein smartes Licht?
Da hatten wir es doch vorhin schon mal.
Ja, ich habe eins, was RGB kann.
Da lasse ich mir anzeigen, wie viel Verspätung.
Dazu kann morgens.
Aber ansonsten bin ich kein Fan von smarter Beleuchtung, was an- und ausschalten angeht,
weil man kann es einfach mit dem Lichtschalter ausschalten.
Ich finde es viel besser, wenn man den Lichtschalter, wenn man da einen Relay einbaut.
Was natürlich ganz cool ist, wenn man RGB-Steuerung haben möchte oder irgendwelche RGB-Beleuchtung
passend zur Stimmung machen will oder sowas.
Ja, dann ist es ganz nett.
Wobei, dann würde ich das mit LED-Leisten machen.
Habe ich nicht.
RGB-Beleuchtung ist bei mir in der Heimautomatisierung noch ziemlich unterrepräsentiert.
Bisschen unter, ja, da muss noch, kommt noch ein bisschen was in Zukunft wahrscheinlich.
Also, was ich gerne hätte, ist zum Beispiel ein Schlafzimmer, eine LED-Leiste, dass man
da quasi morgens anderes Licht machen kann, wie abends zum Einschlafen oder eben halt
auch, wenn man einfach mal da Licht auf dem Tablet irgendwie mal ein bisschen was anguckt,
dass man dann das passende Licht, das würde ich gerne machen.
Aber das ist bei mir auf der Prioritätsmodus ganz unten.
Jetzt mal das Licht starten wir.
Benutzt du den Mann- oder den Frau-Modus-Zugang?
Das Klo ist standardmäßig genderneutral, also voll auf der Höhe der Zeit, ja.
Hast du Stromausfall, dann ist das Klo nicht mehr spülen.
Die Spülung, die ist analog.
Das ist ein ganz normaler Wasserkasten, wo du draufdrückst und dann kommt die Spülung.
Ja, das ist ein ganz normaler Wasserkasten, wo du draufdrückst und dann kommt die Spülung.
Das Spülen für den Bobbes, für den Hintern, das geht natürlich ohne Strom nicht.
IP liegt, oh fuck.
Oh fuck, IP liegt, Leute.
Monka S.
Monka Shake, Monka Smoke, Alter.
Ja, das gefällt Twitch Chat.
Video, wo ich die Klos geflamed habe, ja.
Ich habe mal die Bahn geflamed, weil es in Hanau keinen ordentlichen Klo gab.
Das war schlimm.
Fernbedienung ist auch nie ins Klo gefallen.
Tablet habe ich öfters mal im Bad, ja.
Was haben wir eigentlich für Themen, Alter?
Was ist hier los?
Ich erzähle jetzt seit 20 Minuten schon über wie ich auf mein Klo kacken gehe und es gucken 150 Leute zu.
Was ist denn hier eigentlich wieder verkehrt?
Was ist hier wieder verkehrt?
Genau, das Klo was bootet.
Ja, du kannst beim...
Du hast bei dem...
Wenn du auf das Frauen-Icon drückst, hast du einen Lady-Dusche-Modus.
Kannst du dann quasi nicht nur hinten, sondern auch vorne spülen lassen.
Was ist der Sinn des Lebens?
Das zu machen, worauf man Bock hat.
So viel wie geht.
Hast du von XNN Smart Home nichts mitgemacht?
Hatte dein Klo schon mal einen Blue Screen?
Ähm...
Das hatte zwar noch keinen Blue Screen, aber das hat sich mal aufgehalten.
Nach einem Filterwechsel.
Dann gingen keine Knöpfe mehr.
Ja.
Aber...
Der Luftfilter.
Aber Reboot hat geregelt.
Dann ging es wieder.
Klopapier falten oder knüllen?
Knüllen.
Ich verstehe Leute nicht, die Klopapier falten.
Das muss so richtig raw...
...werden.
Review vom Klo habe ich schon.
Habe ich schon.
Gibt es bei mir auf YouTube.
Hier.
Klo Review.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels.
Auf YouTube.
100.000 Aufrufe.
Klo Review.
Da war es noch ganz neu.
Damals habe ich noch nicht mal gecheckt, dass man die Fernbedienung unten noch ausziehen kann.
Ja.
Wie kann ich in PHP MQTT steuern?
Am besten wahrscheinlich über einen Shell Befehl.
Es gibt 100 pro.
1000 pro.
Eine MQTT.
PHP Library.
Garantiert.
Ha. Das finde ich cool.
Serious Marks.
Das finde ich cool.
Monka Smoke.
Wenn irgendwelche China Dinger abbrennen.
Was haltet ihr von dem Remote?
Oder den hier.
Das finde ich richtig gut.
Weichere ich mir mal.
Das finde ich auch nice.
Das dritte gefällt mir auch am besten.
Also mir gefällt es auch.
Also mir gefällt das dritte am besten.
Die Frage ist, wie das aussieht, wenn es klein ist.
Ähm.
Das schreiben wir auf das Mama.
Bis ich Partner bin.
Ähm.
Mussten wir uns da leider mit einem
Better Twitch TV Emote begnügen.
Ja, aber Serious Marks, das ist cool.
MQTT Library.
CE auf Kleber mitbestellen für China Geräte.
Beste.
Ähm.
Gibt es schon ein eigenes Tool für Abstimmung?
Nein, gibt es noch nicht.
Da nehmen wir einfach Straw Pool für.
Ähm.
Welche Bar benutzt du mit I3?
Das Ding nennt sich äh.
I3 Status Rust.
Das da.
Das verwende ich.
So übrigens Leute.
Ich habe euch gesagt, 22 Uhr ist Schluss.
Ich muss pennen und äh.
Arbeiten gehen morgen.
Und überhaupt.
Gucken wir mal.
Oh fuck.
Ich habe die VM ausgemacht.
Jetzt läuft natürlich auch das PPGA Board nicht mehr.
Ja, ich weiß ja.
Heute ist outdated.
Okay Leute, ich muss ins Bett.
Sonst wäre ich noch länger aufgeblieben.
Ähm.
Wir machen jetzt Schluss an der Stelle.
Original ist beste.
Also.
Machts gut.
Bis zum nächsten Stream.
CU.
Outro.